mes chers collègues
je vous rappelle que normalement le
temps prévu pour cette mission est de 3
heures
avec
[Musique]
50 amendements c'est ça
inutile de vous dire que ça paraît un
peu compliqué alors la proposition c'est
plutôt
d'essayer de tenir en 3h30 c'est-à-dire
de rajouter une demi-heure
mais ça veut dire de pour chacun que ce
soit dans la discussion générale dans
les amendements de faire bref parce que
derrière il y a l'aide publique au
développement et ce soir les articles
non rattachés la parole est à Monsieur
Vincent Delahaye rapporteur spécial de
la commission des finances pour 7
minutes vous avez la parole chers
collègues
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui les crédits
de la mission action extérieure de
l'État qui porte la majorité des moyens
des ministère des Affaires étrangères
aux côtés de la mission aide publique au
développement
le projet de loi de finances pour 2023
demande d'ouverture de 3,2 milliards
d'euros de crédit en autorisation
d'engagement comment crédit de paiement
les crédits augmenteraient ainsi de 5,2
% valeur et de 0,9% une fois corrigé de
l'inflation
l'essentiel de la hausse des crédits
s'explique par les évolutions sur trois
grands postes de dépenses
le premier poste concerne les dépenses
de personnel qui augmenteront de 64
millions cette année
l'évolution des dépenses de personnel
témoignent d'un véritable relâchement
des efforts qui avait été entrepris par
le ministère et je dirais même d'une
forme de reniement au détriment de nos
finances publiques
depuis l'année dernière le ministère
s'est engagé dans une réforme de
rémunérations qui se traduit par une
augmentation de 30 millions d'euros en
cumulé des mesures catégorielles
en parallèle rien n'a véritablement été
fait pour maîtriser réformer les
indemnités de résidence à l'étranger
merci mes chers collègues merci de ne
pas trop avoir de conversation à
l'intérieur de l'émission je vous en
prie voilà j'étais en train de dire
monsieur le Président merci depuis
l'année dernière le ministère s'est
engagé dans une réforme des
rémunérations qui se traduit par une
augmentation de 30 millions d'euros en
cumulé des mesures catégorielles en
parallèle rien n'a véritablement été
fait pour maîtriser et réformer les
indemnités de résidence à l'étranger
dont le coût progressera de 30 millions
d'euros en 2023 je plaide avec mon
collègue Cora porteur Rémi Féraud que je
salue depuis longtemps
c'est pas depuis longtemps que je salue
c'est que je plaide depuis longtemps
pour que ces indemnités soient révisées
d'une part elles sont versées à des
niveaux bien éloignés environ 25% de
plus de ce qu'une prise en compte des
conditions objectives de travail
justifierait on pourrait progressivement
les rapprocher du montant normal sans
trop de difficultés
d'autre part ces indemnités continuent
d'être défiscalisées ce qui n'est pas
acceptable l'état paie deux fois en
versant l'indemnité et en se privant de
l'imposition sur le revenu enfin le
budget prévoit la création d'environ 100
équivalent temps plein ce qui efface
ainsi un tiers des efforts réalisés dans
le cadre d'action publique 2022
j'avais déjà eu l'occasion de regretter
que le ministère des Affaires étrangères
n'avait pas au bout de la réforme action
publique 2022 et ne réalise pas
l'ensemble des efforts qui lui étaient
demandés
j'observe donc qu'en plus de ne pas
avoir atteint ces objectifs le ministère
les efface pour un tiers dès cette année
cela ne participe pas à donner crédit à
la parole de l'État et du gouvernement
dans son engagement d'assainir nos
finances publiques
le deuxième poste d'évolution des
dépenses concernent les contributions
internationales versées par la France
Rémy Ferro et moi-même avons réalisé
cette année un contrôle sur les
contributions internationales
versées par la France au terme du quai
nous avons noté que la France devait
prendre conscience de la perte
d'influence qu'elle avait subi au cours
des dernières années faute d'investir
suffisamment
en 2023 les contributions
internationales augmenteront de 55
millions d'euros j'aimerais dire que ces
crédits traduisent une montée en
puissance de notre participation à
certaines organisations mais la réalité
est qu'il s'agit surtout de maintenir
les crédits à niveau constant compte
tenu de la dépréciation de l'euro face
au dollar
nous observons en effet que la
dépréciation de l'euro entraîne une
augmentation de 52 millions d'euros sur
les contributions versées en dollars ou
en francs suisses
cependant nous voudrions décerner un
satisfait site au ministère de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères qui a
enclenché le mécanisme de couverture de
change très tôt permettant ainsi
d’éviter d'importantes pertes de change
qui pourrait s'élever à environ 20
millions d'euros si les paiements
avaient lieu dans trois mois
enfin les dépenses immobilières
augmentent de plus de 20 millions
d'euros ce qui s'explique par les effets
de l'inflation et une programmation
dynamique il s'agit en premier lieu de
dépenses courantes d'entretien qui
augmente sous l'effet de la hausse des
prix de l'énergie les dépenses
d'investissement à l'étranger augmentent
pour mettre en œuvre le schéma directeur
toujours avec Rémi Féraud on se quitte
pas nous conduisons actuellement une
mission de contrôle sur l'immobilier du
ministère des Affaires étrangères
beaucoup restent à faire notamment pour
déterminer une stratégie de financement
pérenne
nous rendrons nos conclusions des 2023
après avoir effectué une visite à Madrid
où nous observerons les mesures prises
dans un pays où les choses sont de la
vie de tous bien faite en la matière
je voudrais terminer en faisant part de
mon appréciation globale des crédits de
la mission d'abord je regrette que la
culture de la recherche d'économie soit
si peu développée au ministère pour vous
rassurer un peu madame la ministre je
dirais que cette remarque me semble
valable pour tous les ministères
malheureusement
à titre d'exemple et crédits de la
communication augmente de 2,5 millions
d'euros pour financer la lutte contre la
désinformation certes le sujet est
important et la somme n'est pas énorme
mais nous aurions pu la trouver ailleurs
afin d'éviter cette augmentation
de la même manière 5,4 millions d'euros
ont été ajoutés pour financer
l'Exposition Universelle d'Osaka quand
d'autres lignes budgétaires auraient pu
servir
par ailleurs le relâchement sur les
dépenses de personnels que j'ai déjà
évoqué me semble plus que critiquable
enfin et j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
en commission des finances je doute très
sincèrement de la crédibilité de la
trajectoire de la programmation
lors de nos travaux préparatoires nos
interlocuteurs du ministère semblaient
un peu découvrir la programmation des
finances publiques sur les trois
prochaines années
or le projet de loi de programmation
prévoit au moins 100 millions d'euros
d'économies d'ici 2025 en euros constant
personne ne semble en mesure d'expliquer
comment ce résultat sera atteint ce qui
est particulièrement préoccupant je suis
donc réservé à titre personnel sur ses
crédits mais je rappelle quand même
qu'ils ont fait l'objet d'une option par
la commission des finances et donc les
membres de la commission des finances
ici présents voteront favorablement et
donnons un avis favorable sur ces
crédits je vous remercie merci monsieur
le Président la parole est maintenant
monsieur Rémy frérot rapporteur spécial
la commission des finances pour 7
minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues après mon
collègue rapporteur spécial Vincent
Delahaye je vais plus particulièrement
évoqué l'administration consulaire ainsi
que la diplomatie culturelle et
d'influence dans cette mission dont
l'augmentation des crédits en volume
c'est-à-dire neutraliser de l'inflation
est très c'est faible et les deux
missions dont j'aurai à parler ont des
moyens qui comme vous le savez sont
particulièrement en tension et qui
représente environ un tiers des crédits
de la mission d'abord les crédits de la
diplomatie culturelle et d'influence
s'élève à près de 300 millions d'euros
en crédit de paiement or a EFE ce qui
représente une hausse de un peu plus de
11 millions d'euros cette augmentation
s'explique notamment et mon collègue
Vincent delave vient de le dire par le
financement de 5,4 millions d'euros
consacrés à l'Exposition Universelle
d'Osaka chaque année
nous découvrons un événement
exceptionnel à financer et nous est
difficile pour notre part de juger de la
rigueur du montant dégagé pour cela en
parallèle nous avons pu constater que la
campagne destination France entraînait
un financement de 5,8 millions d'euros
en 2023 qui reste porté par les crédits
de la mission et je tenais à vous dire
madame la ministre nous nous en étonnons
puisqu'en effet la compétence tourisme a
été transférée au ministère de
l'économie et des finances et à tous
France ne fait désormais plus partie des
opérateurs relevant de la diplomatie
culturelle et d'influence en ce qui
concerne les instituts français à
l'étranger je constate que les moyens
sont stables en valeur mais cela
représente une source d'inquiétude
puisque une perte de ressources en
volume est à prévoir du fait de
l'inflation souvent un peu plus élevé
dans les pays concernés qu'en France et
d'autant plus que ces instituts
présentent déjà un déficit d'environ 43
millions d'euros en 2022 qui devrait
donc être amené à s'accentuer en effet
les documents bud commentaire montre que
certaines dépenses liées notamment au
salaire augmente de manière
significative nous interrogeons donc sur
la capacité de la dotation en euros à
préserver un niveau d'activité correct
alors qu'elle reste stable en valeur des
amendements ont été déposés en ce sens
par certains de nos collègues je pense
que le gouvernement devra prendre le
temps d'explication vis-à-vis des
instituts français et de leur stabilité
financière en matière d'attractivité
universitaire les crédits dédiés au
financement des bourses pour les
étudiants et chercheurs étrangers
s'élèvent à 59 millions d'euros comme
l'an dernier cependant ce montant stable
ne doit pas cacher que ces crédits sont
chaque année sous consommés et que ce
phénomène peut d'une certaine manière
être considéré de deux façons soit il y
a une marge de manœuvre budgétaire y
compris pour encaisser les effets de
l'inflation soit d'un autre point de vue
on peut regretter le manque de
volontarisme politique malgré les
discours du président de la République
dans son mandat précédent pour que
l'ensemble des crédits doit utiliser et
que le nombre d'étudiants étrangers
accueillis en France augmente enfin les
crédits du réseau consulaire hors bourse
aux élèves de l'agence de l'enseignement
français à l'étranger s'élève à 285,9
millions d'euros connaissent une hausse
de 2%, bien que aucun crédit ne soit
dédié l'an prochain à l'organisation
d'élection cependant n'oublions pas que
l'essentiel de cette enveloppe est
consacrée au crédit consulaire notamment
à leurs dépenses de personnel et par
ailleurs je veux rappeler que le
programme 151 a supporté pendant des
années la plus grande part des efforts
de maîtrise des effectifs de la mission
ayant entraîné la suppression de 169
équivalent temps plein entre 2018 et
2021 cette baisse c'est d'ailleurs avéré
difficilement soutenable et le ministère
a ainsi recréé 136 ETP et lancer le
service France consulaire pour
mutualiser la prise en charge des appels
au poste consulaire sur un site du Quai
d'Orsay situé à la cour donc une grande
part des efforts réalisés dans le cadre
d'action publique 2022 pour diminuer le
nombre d'agents publics à l'étranger a
été annulé on peut considérer qu'il est
dommages d'annuler si brutalement un
effort considérable de réduction
d'effectifs ou bien en conclure comme je
le fais plutôt pour ma part que ces
efforts étaient si déraisonnable que le
gouvernement a dû revenir dessus en tout
état de cause cette situation interroge
sur la cohérence de la politique
gouvernementale de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques en ce qui concerne la EFE ces
moyens sont renforcés mais plusieurs
points d'alerte demeure ainsi la
subvention pour charge de service public
en hausse de 28 millions d'euros dont 10
millions d'euros correspondent à une
part de l'aide française versée au lycée
à travers le soutien à l'enseignement
français dans le pays au Liban augmente
donc et atteint
441,2 millions d'euros ne faudrait-il
d'ailleurs pas envisager de regrouper
autrement les crédits destiné à l'aide
légitime à portée par la France au Liban
par ailleurs si les crédits pour les
bourses aux élèves de la EFE augmentent
de 10 millions d'euros nous ne devons
pas oublier qu'il faudra faire face
courant de l'année 2023 à une très forte
inflation qui touche les frais de
scolarité dans certains pays du monde
l'impact de CO sur les bourses nappe n'a
pas été inscrit dans le budget et il y a
là une vraie source de préoccupation qui
nous a été relayée car si le surplus
nécessaire pour le versement des bourses
a été pris en charge ces dernières
années par la Soult de la EFE la réserve
n'est plus aujourd'hui que de 15,5
millions d'euros devrait être épuisé à
la fin 2023 ainsi la question de
l'augmentation des crédits de bourse se
posera en 2024 forcément et peut-être
même avant
pour conclure je souhaiterais rappeler
qu'il nous faut considérer cette mission
avec attention parce qu'elle est
certainement la seule à subir à la fois
les effets de l'inflation et du risque
de change parmi l'ensemble des missions
du budget de l'État à court terme les
crédits qui restent contraints demeurent
stable en valeur et diminue très peu en
volume à moyen terme cependant une
baisse en volume de l'ordre de 100
millions d'euros est prévu d'ici 2025
sur l'ensemble de la mission comme le
rappelait mon collègue Vincent Delahaye
je ne suis pas sûr que cette baisse soit
crédible et je ne pense pas par ailleurs
qu'elle soit souhaitable en effet les
économies antérieures ont mis en tension
le réseau et il apparaît désormais
nécessaire de redonner les crédits
effectifs suffisants si nous voulons
préserver notre présence auprès de nos
compatriotes à l'étranger et si nous
voulons développer véritablement notre
diplomatie d'influence dans le monde et
au vu de la loi de programmation nous
pouvons avoir des interrogations donc
nous appelons en effet au nom de la
Commission à approuver les crédits de
cette mission
mais je ne doute pas que le que le Sénat
pardon sera vigilant sur les enjeux que
je rappelais à l'instant cette année
mais aussi et je dirais surtout dans les
années
ultérieures de ce quinquennat je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Jean-Pierre Grand
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères pour 3 minutes
le lundi 1er décembre
mardi
nous nous félicitons que les crédits
annulés en mars et bien été ouvert au
mois d'août suivant les recommandations
de notre commission de même la
couverture de 90% du risque de change
des contributions internationales les
opérations maintient de la paix en 2022
et de bonnes gestion il faudra
poursuivre ses efforts en 2023 car en
27,9 millions sont prévus pour couvrir
les risques échanges prix mais la hausse
des dépenses d'énergie et des dépenses
courantes nous fait craindre que les
provisions ne soient pas suffisantes
nous devons donc y être attentif
la politique immobilière à l'étranger
reste à réinventer en urgence faire
dépendre d'entretien normal des
bâtiments des recettes exceptionnelles
de cession d'immeubles et de comptes
affectations spéciales 723 était une
erreur nous avons longuement parlé le
fonctionnement du compte d'affectation
spéciale n'a pas permis la mise à
disposition de la dotation
exceptionnelle de 36 millions prévus en
2022 nous serons attentifs à ce qu'elles
le Soi cette année le lancement par
session appauvrit l'état il s'essouffle
les ventes deviennent difficiles à
réaliser leurs produits et fléchés vers
le financement de des travaux du Quai
d'Orsay pour 60,8 millions d'euros il
est donc nécessaire d'augmenter les
crédits budgétaires portés à 50,2
millions les crédits et 50,7 millions
pour les autorisations d'engagement en
2023 ses moyens restent insuffisants la
dotation budgétaire annuelle doit être
fixé à 80 millions
par an et 90 en autorisation
d'engagement afin de permettre la
réalisation des schémas pluriels de
stratégie immobilière enfin nous avons
un dernier point d'attention sur
l'application de la réforme de
l'encadrement supérieur de l'État au
ministère des Affaires étrangères la
commission recommandée notamment de
reprendre le dialogue avec les
personnels et d'associer le Parlement à
la réfection satisfaction nous a été
donnée avec le lancement des états
généraux de la diplomatie qui doivent
aboutir au plus tard à la fin du premier
trimestre 2023 nous veillerons au
renforcement de notre appareil
diplomatique essentiel dans le monde
dangereux instable et de moins en moins
prévisible je salue les efforts déployés
par tous les personnels du ministère
pour faire face à ces chocs et crises
stratégiques majeur et garantir le
rayonnement de la France la Commission a
adopté les crédits de cette mission
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur André gatolin
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
aux Affaires étrangères pour 3 minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le
programme 105 est une priorité de la
mission action extérieure de l'État et
ce caractérise cette année encore par
des évolutions qui étaient réclamés par
notre commission notamment la poursuite
de l'augmentation des contributions
volontaires aux organisations
internationales le pilotage du programme
est contraint par le poids du réseau
d'abord et par les contributions
internationales qui représentent près de
70% des crédits dans ce contexte un
effort particulier et mené depuis 2017
pour retrouver des marges de manœuvre
afin de restaurer une influence de la
France en 2020 aux Nations unies la
France est devenue le sixième
contributeur obligatoire en raison de la
peste baisse de la quote-part française
au budget des opérations de maintien de
la paix et au budget régulier de l'ONU
malgré les efforts notables de ces trois
dernières années nous ne sommes que le
neuvième contributeur volontaire
l'Allemagne et verse respectivement 10
fois et cinq fois plus de contribution
volontaires que la France en 2020 pour
trouver la réponse adéquate à cette
situation dès 2017 le meae c'est doté
d'un comité de pilotage des
contributions internationales et
opérations de maintien de paix celui-ci
définit et programme nous contributions
volontaires à verser dans l'année pour
2023 elles atteindront plus de 58
millions d'euros et placeront la France
au 7e rang des contributeurs globaux la
France a ainsi regagné trois rangs par
rapport à 2019 outre ce classement
amélioré des résultats concrets sont à
mettre à l'actif du ministère nous
pouvons ainsi nous réjouir d'avoir gardé
la tête du Département des opérations de
paix à l'ONU d'avoir pesé sur le
lancement d'une enquête sur la situation
en Ukraine par le Bureau du Procureur de
la Cour pénale internationale ou encore
d'avoir intégré le groupe des 12 plus
grands contributeurs au fond de
consolidation pour la paix ce dernier
nous donne une voix délivrative
désormais sur la définition des
orientations stratégiques nous pouvons
ainsi orienter l'action du fond vers des
zones que nous jugeons prioritaire tels
que les Balkans ou encore l'Ukraine nous
avons été à l'initiative aussi du
lancement de la stratégie des Nations
Unies sur la lutte contre la
désinformation grâce à notre position de
premier contributeur aux actions du
Département des opérations de paix en
matière de sécurité notre soutien accru
à l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique a constitué un complément utile
aux efforts menées sur le dossier du
nucléaire européen iranien pardon nous
contribuons nos contributions
volontaires à l'organisation pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques ont
permis de soutenir le travail de terrain
tant sur le dossier chimique syrien que
plus récemment en Ukraine en conclusion
la commission se prononce donc
favorablement
sur ces crédits de la mission pour
l'action extérieure de l'État je vous
remercie si chers collègues la parole
est maintenant monsieur Ronan legleux
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il est désormais
admis que les luttes d'influence sont au
cœur de la compétition mondiale
en la matière la France dispose d'un
contestable Zattoo premier réseau
culturel du monde
premier réseau éducatif troisième réseau
diplomatique pour autant la place de la
France n'est pas immuable au cours du
précédent quinquennat le gouvernement
affiché des ambitions élevées pour la
diplomatie culturelle et d'influence de
notre pays ambition reprise dans une
feuille de route de l'influence
présentée en décembre 2021 par Jean-Yves
Le Drian
pour autant forcer de constater qu'un
fossé c'est creusé entre les discours et
les actes
ainsi en 2023 les crédits du programme
185 progresseront de 40 millions d'euros
à périmètre constant dont 30 millions
iront à l'Agence pour l'enseignement
français à l'étranger la EFE ce qui nous
est présenté comme une hausse importante
des moyens de l'agence ne vise en
réalité qu'à compensé des dépenses
supplémentaires
l'aide nécessaire au réseau de
l'enseignement français au Liban
l'augmentation tout aussi nécessaire du
point d'indice et enfin la mise en place
d'un nouveau statut pour les personnels
détachés
sur ce dernier point les crédits ouverts
en projet de loi de finances ne
permettront que de couvrir la moitié du
surcoût
lors de votre audition devant notre
commission madame la ministre vous vous
étiez voulu rassurante on nous indiquant
que l'autre moitié de ce surcoût serait
financé par un reliquat de crédit ouvert
en 2020 il n'en est pourtant rien loin
d'une augmentation de ses moyens
l'agence devra donc faire face à une
dépense supplémentaire de 7 millions
d'euros en 2023 et cette dépense à
vocation accroître des 2024
cette augmentation voir cette régression
des moyens de l'EFE n'a néanmoins pas
conduit le gouvernement a interrogé
l'objectif présidentiel de doubler les
effectifs du nombre d'élèves du réseau
de l'AEFE d'ici 2030 lequel apparaît
désormais irréaliste
en effet selon nos calculs et comme vous
pouvez le voir ici la projection nous
montre que au rythme de croissance des
effectifs actuels cet objectif ne sera
atteint qu'en 2049
en tout état de cause l'augmentation du
nombre d'élèves ne saurait constituer
l'unique boussole de l'enseignement
français à l'étranger en effet nous
avons été alertés sur le risque de
développement d'une concurrence entre
établissements c'est pourquoi nous
appelons à la mise en place d'une
véritable carte scolaire établie par la
fe afin de garantir un développement
harmonieux du réseau par ailleurs la
croissance du réseau ne doit pas être
entravée par la question du financement
des investissements immobiliers des
établissements en gestion direct qui
n'est toujours pas résolu c'est pourquoi
nous proposons qu'une subvention pour
charge d'investissement soit inscrite
dès le PLF 2024 en conclusion mes chers
collègues vous l'aurez compris ce PLF ne
nous semble pas à la hauteur d'une
politique d'influence réellement
ambitieuse pour autant les crédits du
programme 185 étant taillé à juste
suffisance la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense a émis un
avis favorable à cette à son adoption je
vous remercie c'est cher collègue la
parole est maintenant monsieur André
Vallini rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des affaires étrangères pour
3 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues sur l'attractivité
de la France en matière de mobilité
étudiante la subvention versée à Campus
France sera stable
et il en va de même pour les crédits
consacrés au bourse aux étudiants si la
croissance du nombre des étudiants
étrangers accueillis en France avait
atteint des taux très élevés dans la
dernière décennie l'augmentation des
moyens qui sont consacrés à cette
politique aurait dû augmenter ce n'est
pas le cas notre pays est en effet en
perte de vitesse dans ce domaine entre
2014 et 2019 la France est passée de la
quatrième place à la septième place dans
le classement des pays qui accueille le
plus d'étudiants en mobilité certes des
mesures ont été prises et notamment en
2018 la stratégie bienvenue France qui
ce bienvenue en France pardon qui se
fixait comme objectif d'accueillir 500
000 étudiants étrangers à l'horizon 2027
ainsi qu'un doublement du nombre de
bourses versées par le MAE mais ces
mesures ne semblent pas suffisantes pour
permettre à la France de je vous cite
même la ministre remontée sur le podium
des nations les plus attractives pour
les étudiants étrangers c'est ce que
vous aviez dit devant la commission
notre pays doit en effet faire face à de
nombreux défis d'abord le décalage entre
les moyens accordés à Campus France
et aux bourses les étudiantes qui
stagnent et les ambitions affichées je
rappelle que le budget allemand consacré
aux mobilité entrantes et trois fois
supérieures aux nôtres deuxièmement la
durée moyenne des bourses de lettres
allongée actuellement elle est de moins
de 6 mois ce qui conduit à un
saupoudrage des moyens et ne permet pas
de créer un lien pérenne avec les
étudiants accueillis troisièmement et
enfin notre système universitaire
souffre on sait bien depuis longtemps de
son manque de lisibilité du fait de la
coexistence d'école et d'université par
ailleurs l'offre d'enseignement en
anglais demeure insuffisante j'en viens
maintenant au deuxième point de mon
intervention la diplomatie culturelle
les actions inscrites dans la feuille de
route dont a parlé Ronan legleux la
feuille de route de l'influence dans ce
domaine nous semble floue et peu
ambitieuse tout au plus savons-nous que
2 millions d'euros leur seront consacrés
en 2023 lesquels seront financés par des
économies dites de constatation je ne
sais toujours pas ce que veut dire
économie de constatation il faudra qu'un
jour on puisse m'expliquer ça enfin les
moyens d'évoluer au réseau culturel
institut français et Alliance française
seront également stables l'année
prochaine
cette stabilité interroge dans un
contexte de fragilisation de certains
établissements du fait de la crise
sanitaire et de l'inflation qui touche
de nombreux pays en conclusion madame la
ministre le budget qui nous est proposé
est un budget sans réel ambition et la
commission l'a adoptée sans réelle
enthousiasme je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
Monsieur Bruno Sidot rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des affaires
étrangères pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur les rapporteurs mesdames
Messieurs chers collègues mon collègue
Guillaume Gontard et moi-même avons
rapporté pour avis les crédits du
programme 151 pour la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
lors de sa réunion du 16 novembre la
Commission a rendu un avis positif sur
l'adoption de ses crédits le programme
151 comporte comme chaque année les
ressources dédiées aux Français à
l'étranger et aux affaires consulaires
elle serait partie sans trois grands
postes de dépenses le service public
pour nos compatriotes à l'étranger pour
environ 60% des crédits le financement
des bourses scolaires du réseau de
l'Agence française pour l'enseignement
la EFE et pour un tiers des crédits et
enfin le traitement des demandes de visa
pour 15% restants l'année 2023 marquera
par ailleurs une forme de retour à la
normale pour le programme sur 51 du fait
de l'absence d'élection directe à
l'échelle nationale pour mémoire
l'organisation des élections
présidentielles plus législatives qui se
sont tenus cette année avaient donné
lieu à Abondance spécifique de 14
millions d'euros en loi de finances pour
2022 nous relevons toutefois que pour
faire face à cette échéance le ministère
avait réduit ponctuellement sa dotation
de financement des bourses scolaires de
près de 10 millions d'euros en
s'appuyant sur la soulte de l'agence
pour maintenir constant le soutien
financier aux familles expatriées ces
deux opérations budgétaires s'étant en
quelque sorte mutuellement neutralisées
en 2022 c'est bien à une stabilisation
des crédits que nous constatons pour
l'année 2023 avec une hausse globale de
5%. par ailleurs nous nous sommes
intéressés plus particulièrement au
déploiement du service France consulaire
le ce service est une innovation mise en
place par le Quai d'Orsay à partir du 13
octobre 2021 il s'agit d'une plateforme
de réponse dématérialisée qui peut être
sollicitée par téléphone ou par courriel
pour les Français résidant à l'étranger
ou le passage à l'étranger sur son
déploiement nous retenons deux
principaux points de vigilance le
premier concert le fait que le service
France consolaire ne serait servir de
prétexte à de nouvelles réductions
d'effectifs madame la ministre le second
concerne le calendrier de déploiement du
dispositif qui est moins ambitieux que
les objectifs initialement annoncés
cette dernière constatation
ne remets pas en cause la réussite de
cette expérimentation elle justifie
néanmoins que nous soyons
particulièrement attentifs à ce que le
déploiement de la France consulaire soit
accompagnée des moyens adéquats je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant au président Guillaume gonta
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères pour 3 minutes
merci merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre chers collègues comme vient
de le rappeler mon collègue bruno Sido
nous avons également travaillé cette
année sur l'action sociale au bénéfice
des Français de l'étranger qui comprend
notamment les crédits portés par le
programme 151 pour financer les bourses
scolaires du réseau de l'Agence pour la
saignement français à l'étranger ou à
EFE les dépenses sociales gérées par les
postes consulaires ont connu plusieurs
années exceptionnelles du fait de la
création en avril 2020 du soutien
occasionnel de solidarité ou appelé
également SOS covid qui correspond à une
aide mensuelle destinée aux français
installé à l'étranger et ont subi des
pertes de revenus liées à la crise
sanitaire la reconduction de cette aide
pendant l'ensemble de l'année 2021 c'est
traduite par un montant exceptionnel
d'aide sociale versée pendant cet
exercice avec 27 millions dont 12
millions pour le seul versement des
aides SOS covid à cet égard
l'augmentation d'environ un million de
l'enveloppe de financement des aides
sociales en 2023 ne peut pas être
présenté sérieusement comme une
compensation équivalente à la
suppression le dispositif SOS covid dont
le montant atteignait plus de 10
millions d'euros en année pleine cette
augmentation limitée du budget de
financement des aides sociales
consulaires et d'autant plus
préoccupante que de nombreux facteurs
sont subtés susceptibles de faire
croître le nombre de nos compatriotes en
situation précaire au cours de
l'exercice 2023 face à une inflation qui
devrait atteindre plus de 6% à l'échelle
mondiale en 2023 les aides sociales qui
ne seront pas revalorisées ris de voir
leur valeur réelle diminuées enfin cette
dégradation de la situation économique
intervient alors que l'administration
consulaire nous a indiqué qu'elle ne
disposait pas d'instruments de mesure du
taux de non recours de ces aides qui
restent inconnues
sur le sujet des bourses scolaires je
rappelle pour mémoire que les bourses
distribuées par le réseau de l'EFE sont
financés par une enveloppe spécifique
pardon prélevé sur les crédits du
programme 151 en 2021 ces bourses ont
bénéficiés à plus de 24000 élèves
répartis dans 137 pays différents pour
un coup de 130 millions d'euros
toutefois j'attire votre attention sur
les défauts de budgétisation de
l'enveloppe de financement des bourses
scolaires dans les dernières années et
en particulier en 2022 les crédits
inscrits en loi de finances initiale ont
été inférieures au coût réel du
financement des bourses scolaires cette
différence était rendue possible par
l'existence d'un excédent de trésorerie
de l'agence appelé Soult qui a financé
pendant plusieurs exercices successifs
le solde entre les crédits votés en loi
de finances et de coût réel des bourses
ce mécanisme nuit à la clarté et à la
lisibilité du dispositif de financement
des bourses scolaires et nous serons
attentifs à ce que à l'avenir les crédit
votés annuellement se rapprochent
évidemment du coût réel des bourses
scolaires je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur Claude Ker en
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
la culture pour 3 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je partage avec mes
collègues rapporteurs spéciaux la
satisfaction de voir progresser des
crédits accordés à la mission action
extérieure de l'État et plus
particulièrement se consacrer à la
diplomatie culturelle et d'influence
dans le contexte très préoccupant que
nous connaissons cette évolution mérite
d'être saluée je mettrai toutefois
plusieurs bémols les points de vigilance
le premier concerne la hausse des moyens
de l'AFE à hauteur de 30 millions
d'euros toute augmentation de crédit est
évidemment bonne à prendre mais celle-ci
vient compenser de nouvelles dépenses et
non donnée des marges de manœuvre
supplémentaire à l'opérateur dont il
aurait pourtant besoin faut-il rappeler
que le rythme moyen de la croissance
annuelle des effectifs est très en deçà
de celui nécessaire pour atteindre
l'objectif présidentiel de doublement
des effectifs de d'ici 2030 pour la
première fois madame la ministre je
constate que vos services reconnaissent
un certain décalage entre l'ambition
affichée et en réalité de la mise en
oeuvre dès 2018 notre commission avait
pour sa part émis de sérieux doute sur
cette faisabilité l'un des principaux
défis structurels posés par la
croissance du réseau c'est l'entretien
et l'agrandissement des établissements
or là et feu n'a plus l'autorisation
d'emprunter pour effectuer des travaux
tandis que les établissements
conventionnés et partenaires peuvent
recourir à la garantie de l'État
l'opérateur est dans une impasse
financière alors que les besoins de
financement immobilier sont évalués à
300 millions d'euros sur les 5
prochaines années c'est pourquoi sur ma
proposition la commission adoptée un
amendement les ré-autorisant à emprunter
celui-ci ayant été déclaré irrecevable
il ne sera pas discuté en séance mais je
souhaite néanmoins madame la ministre
connaître votre position sur ce sujet
j'ajoute que la commission de la culture
a également décidé de proposer la
suppression de l'article 41 a mon
deuxième bémol porte sur les instituts
français les Alliances françaises la
stabilisation de un budget risque de se
heurter dès les premiers mois de 2023 la
dégradation de leur situation financière
compte tenu de l'effet ciseaux provoqué
par l'inflation des redéploiements de
crédit vers les structures les plus
fragilisées devront sans doute être
envisagés mon troisième et dernier point
de vigilance concerne l'Institut
français de Paris dont le modèle
économique est en pleine évolution la
baisse puis la relative stabilisation
des financements apportés par ces deux
tutelles l'ont en effet contraint à
diversifier ses ressources dans ce
contexte il me semble important que le
prochain Coop soit l'occasion de
remettre à plat le subventionnement de
ces tutelles au regard des missions de
service public qu'à lui confie
je déplore d'ores et déjà quand vous les
moyens ne soient pas à l'ordre du jour
madame la ministre quelles sont vos
intentions pour ce nouveau contrat sous
le bénéfice de ces observations la
commission de la culture a émis un avis
favorable à l'adoption des crédits du
programme 185 je vous remercie merci
chers collègues dans la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Mélanie
Vogel pour le groupe écologiste pour 5
minutes
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues la mission
budgétaire que nous étudions aujourd'hui
peut sembler à première vue aller dans
la bonne direction pour la première fois
en 30 ans l'administration du Quai
d'Orsay va connaître une augmentation de
personnel et je le salue la mission
action extérieure de l'État va connaître
une hausse de ses moyens financiers à
hauteur de 160 millions d'euros
évidemment on ne peut que se réjouir de
voir que les moyens mis à disposition
sont à la hausse sauf que pour
l'essentiel c'est os sont en trompe
l'oeil prenez par exemple l'augmentation
du budget il permet à peine de contenir
l'inflation actuelle une hausse qui
s'explique d'ailleurs en partie parce
que les contributions internationales de
la France en dollars coûtent plus cher
en raison de la faiblesse de l'euro une
hausse qui est en partie forcée pour
satisfaire à la revalorisation du point
d'indice des fonctionnaires et parce que
le coût des indemnités de résidence à
l'étranger ont augmenté
nous avons ainsi un peu de mal à voir
dans cette mission budgétaire 2023 où
sont les crédits supplémentaires pour
réparer notre réseau diplomatique et
consulaire qui est lui aboutsouffle
prenons maintenant l'augmentation du
nombre de postes équivalent en plein on
parle d'une centaine de nouveaux postes
c'est bien mais ce ministère est
certainement celui qui a le plus
souffert depuis 10 ans des cures
d'austérité c'est plus du tiers de ces
effectifs qui ont été perdus depuis 2018
ce sont plus de 200 postes qui ont été
supprimés sans oublier les 500 postes en
moins dans mon lycée français de
l'étranger aussi la hausse de sangos ne
compense en rien les pertes précédentes
pirent encore on évoque la création de
seulement une dizaine de postes pour le
réseau consulaire une espèce de brigade
volante de pompiers qui interviendrait
dans les consulats en sous-effectif
chronique il faudrait en réalité
10 fois 20 fois plus de personnel pour
soulager nos équipes consulaires qui ont
été en première ligne lors de la crise
du covid et nous en avons encore besoin
maintenant j'ai la chance ici de
représenter au Sénat les Françaises et
les Français qui vivent hors de France
et je suis témoin tous les jours tous
les jours du dysfonctionnement de l'État
que ce soit dans l'émission des actes
civils dépasseport des cartes d'identité
pour nous concitoyens des concitoyens
qui met parfois plus de six mois avec
toutes les conséquences que cela
implique sans oublier le service des
visas que ce soit dans le des engagement
progressifs de l'État dans notre réseau
d'enseignement français à l'étranger que
ce soit dans notre réseau diplomatique
avec les ambitions présidentielles de
chambouler le système et de diminuer le
nombre de diplomates de carrière ou
encore dans notre réseau consulaire
pardon culturel qui se sont souvent
oubliés par le gouvernement comme nos
alliances françaises ou nos instituts
avec des budgets stabilisés malgré
l'inflation alors oui nous sommes
inquiets de constater que cette mission
budgétaire
n'est pas à la hauteur des crises
environnementales économiques
géopolitiques que subissent nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyens
les Français et les Français de
l'étranger ne sont pas
dans leur grande majorité des VRP de la
start-up nation ce sont aussi des
fonctionnaires des employés des
étudiantes et des étudiants des
retraités des chômeurs des chômeuses il
y a une chose qui les relie tout et tous
et que ce sont d'abord et avant tout des
citoyennes et des citoyens qui sont
parfois dans des situations économiques
compliquées qui voient les frais de
scolarité de leurs enfants exploser qui
voient leur retraite amputées juste
parce que il est elles ont passé une
partie de leur carrière à l'étranger et
qui sont pourtant les premiers
ambassadeurs et ambassadrices de la
France dans le monde mais la mission
budgétaire que nous examinons
aujourd'hui n'apporte pas de solutions
pérennes à leurs inquiétudes tout comme
d'ailleurs elle ne semble pas offrir de
vision à long terme de l'action
extérieure de la France peut-être comme
l'a fait remarquer notre collègue
Aurélien taché à l'Assemblée nationale
parce que le Quai d'Orsay est le seul
grand ministère régalien à ne pas avoir
de loi de programmation pluriannuelles
enfin pour terminer le groupe écologie
s'inquiètent de constater que rien ou si
peu n'est présent dans cette mission
budgétaire concernant la transition
écologique
je cherchais pourtant dans les trois
programmes qui constituent cette mission
j'ai pas vu grand chose sinon
saupoudrage superficiel évoquant ici
l'attribution de bourse make-up planète
great again OK ou là la mise en forme de
normes aux normes environnementales de
la climatisation dans nos bâtiments en
Arabie Saoudite je suis pas contre c'est
bien il n'y a rien qui prouve que ce
gouvernement a réellement pris la mesure
de l'urgence écologique qui devrait
pourtant être l'une des principales
préoccupations lorsqu'il s'agit de
déterminer et de financer les actions de
l'État y compris à l'étranger pour
toutes ces raisons le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoires ne votera pas
la mission budgétaire action extérieure
de l'État je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Samantha casse bonne
pour le groupe RDPI pour 6 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues je me réjouis de pouvoir
intervenir au nom du groupe RDPI sur
l'examen des crédits de la mission
action extérieure de l'État le Quai
d'Orsay disposera cette année encore
d'un budget au-dessus de la barre
symbolique des 5 milliards et en hausse
avec
6,6 milliards d'euros en 2023 donc 3,2
milliards pour la mission action
extérieure elle-même en hausse de plus
de 5%. ce budget s'inscrit au service
d'un objectif primordial rappelé par le
Président de la République lors de la
conférence des ambassadeurs en septembre
à savoir faire en sorte que la France
demeure une puissance d'équilibre
capable par ricochet d'appuyer
l'autonomie stratégique de l'Europe est
capable d'agir efficacement en faveur du
multi latéralisme et de trouver des
voies diplomatiques à la résolution des
conflits
c'est avant tout un budget qui vient
muscler notre action diplomatique en
Europe et dans le monde face aux
nombreux défis qui nous préoccupent
comme vient de le présenter notre
collègue rapporteur André gatelin la
poursuite de la hausse de nos
contributions volontaires aux
organisations internationales y
participera pleinement je m'en réjouis
car les efforts de ces dernières années
produisent des résultats tangibles aussi
bien dans le domaine du maintien de la
paix que de la sécurité internationale
pour la première fois depuis 30 ans ce
budget en hausse s'accompagnera d'une
création nette d'emploi de 106 ETP
équivalent temps plein dont une partie
bénéficiera au réseau consulaire c'est
inédit ce souffle nouveau ne se ne sera
pas trop évidemment face à la
multiplication des crises
internationales c'est dans ce contexte
que le budget du centre de crise et de
soutien sera lui aussi rehaussée de 600
millions d'euros en 2023
ces agents auprès de nos postes
diplomatiques ne ménage pas leurs
efforts pour venir en aide à nos
compatriotes en danger dans des zones de
conflits et je les salue
j'aimerais d'ailleurs souligner un enjeu
qui me paraît crucial et
urgent celui du renforcement de notre
communication et de notre lutte contre
la désinformation et la propagande
hostile ces menaces sont souvent
d'origine russe chinoise et turcs et
particulièrement présente en Afrique et
en Europe nous actons dans ce budget 2,5
millions d'euros supplémentaires enfin
nous resterons pour notre part très
vigilant quant à la sécurisation de nos
emprises diplomatiques et consulaires en
particulier lorsqu'elles se situe par
Don dans des zones instables et sujettes
à des risques d'attentat
c'est ensuite un budget qui poursuit la
traduction dans les actes de la feuille
de route de l'influence lancée par votre
prédécesseur madame la ministre avec une
hausse de 13 millions d'euros des
crédits dédiés à la diplomatie
culturelle et d'influence l'enjeu est de
taille car bon nombre de nos
compétiteurs accordent eux-mêmes des
moyens conséquents la matière pour
remettre en cause notre action nous
serons donc attentifs quant à
l'évolution de notre coopération
universitaire et de recherche à la
promotion de l'influence culturelle et
interculturelle française à l'étranger
et au niveau de la diffusion de la
langue française et le développement de
l'enseignement francophone à cet égard
je me félicite de que la quasi-totalité
des hausses de crédit du programme 185
soit dédié à l'enseignement français à
l'étranger avec 30 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour l'agence
d'enseignement français à l'étranger
alors que vient d'être confirmé la
grande consultation tente attendue qui
permettra à l'ensemble des acteurs de
faire des propositions concertées dès le
mois prochain de ce que doivent être les
conditions d'un développement qualitatif
de notre réseau d'enseignement scolaire
à l'étranger c'est un abondement
historique que je tenais à saluer je
pense également aux associations flammes
qui permettent aux élèves français
scolarisés dans d'autres systèmes
éducatifs de consolider leur maîtrise de
la langue et de la culture française le
président les a salués lors de son
discours devant la Communauté française
à Washington il y a quelques jours
encore comme étant une priorité pour nos
jeunesses j'espère d'ailleurs que les
jeunes Français de l'étranger pourront
bientôt bénéficier d'un pass éducation
langue française pour s'y inscrire enfin
ce budget est aussi un budget au service
des Français établis hors de France que
je représente aujourd'hui avec 141
millions d'euros dédiés je veux
remercier nos agents qui au contact de
nos concitoyens établis hors de France
comme de passage et qui les protège et
les accompagne dans diverses situations
de détresse ces dernières années
plusieurs pays ont pris la décision de
réduire la couverture dans le monde de
leur réseau consulaires ce n'est pas le
chemin qui a emprunté la France mieux
encore nous avons choisi de lancer un
vaste chantier de modernisation de notre
action consulaire afin d'améliorer
l'accessibilité au service public
consulaire pour nos concitoyens je pense
par exemple au nouveau service
d'information et de réponses aux appels
des Français de l'étranger dénommé
France consulaire son expérimentation
depuis octobre 2021 dans plusieurs pays
européens et une réussite et son
déploiement dès cette fin d'année à
l'ensemble des pays d'Europe est
attendus le filet de sécurité et de
solidarité exceptionnelle liées au covid
est emmené pardon un autre bel exemple
dès 2020 le gouvernement s'est mobilisé
pour les Français hors du territoire
national ayant subi des pertes revenus
liés à la crise sanitaire une aide
mensuelle a ainsi été proposé pour qu'il
puisse faire face comme leurs
concitoyens en France à cette situation
unique je me félicite que cette aide et
d'ailleurs été reconduite en 2021 puis
en 2022 tente elle était nécessaire
enfin le budget 2023 coordination
particulière à l'aide sociale apportée
aux Français de l'étranger les plus
démunis avec une enveloppe d'un million
d'euros je me joindrai aux inquiétudes
formulées par notre collègue rapporteur
Guillaume gonta pardon pour
pour vous faire part de l'attention que
portera le groupe RDPI dans les
prochains mois quant aux perspectives de
récession et à l'inflation dans certains
pays nous voterons donc en faveur votre
budget merci les offres de ne pas
dépasser leur temps je vous rappelle que
nous avons 50 amendements et seulement
trois heures et demie parce que nous
avons ajouté 30 minutes sur l'ensemble
de la mission si vous ne voulez pas que
je report la fin de la mission après les
articles non rattachés ça voudra dire à
minuit et demi
troisième orateur dans la discussion
générale madame Hélène Queneau et Mouret
pour le groupe socialiste pour 9 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la France a fait le
choix d'un modèle que de nombreux pays
nous envient d'imiter celui d'un réseau
complet à la fois diplomatique
consulaire éducatif culturel et
économique c'est un héritage
exceptionnel que nous avons le devoir de
préserver aujourd'hui madame la ministre
vous allez nous inviter à nous réjouir
de l'augmentation des crédits et des
postes il est vrai que l'inversion de la
courbe budgétaire que nous appelons de
nos vœux depuis longtemps et vraiment la
bienvenue et pourtant l'augmentation de
5% des crédits de la mission action
extérieure de l'État n'est
malheureusement ni structurante pour
l'avenir du ministère ni l'expression
d'une volonté politique de changement
puisqu'elle sera absorbée principalement
par l'inflation et la dépréciation de
l'euro par ailleurs le saupoudrage des
crédits ne permettra de financer aucune
nouvelle mesure la création de son site
TP présentée comme le réarmement de la
diplomatie française est loin de
compenser les 160 postes supprimés sur
la seule année 2019 et qui prend ce que
forme l'ensemble des personnels et nos
conseillers des Français étrangers a
fait preuve d'une grande résilience
durant la pandémie est un élan spontané
de solidarité à chaque crise pour
empêcher le tissu social de se déchirer
s'il mérite notre reconnaissance sont
surtout le moyen humain et financiers à
hauteur de leur mission dont ils ont
besoin je voudrais maintenant parler de
notre action consulaire en particulier
la qualité des services publics offert
aux Français de l'étranger et notre
politique des visas et consulat devait
être les premiers lieux d'accueil de nos
compatriotes à l'étranger mais sur de
moins en moins accessibles
paradoxalement les usagers parviennent
très difficiles à obtenir un rendez-vous
faute de personnel et la
dématérialisation sont ces facilités
leurs démarches les plus élémentaires
prive une partie de la population
d'accès au service public elle doit
vraiment demeurer un outil
supplémentaire par ailleurs très utile
et ne pas être utilisé pour une
politique de suppression de poste et
d'économies le choix de l'externative
l'externalisation montre lui aussi ses
limites le service France consulaire
mise en place pour pallier la
suppression des accueils téléphoniques
dans les consulats nécessitent
finalement des crédits important de
l'ordre de 1,9 millions d'euros en 2023
et mobilise des personnels
supplémentaires du ministère à Paris
est-il vraiment judicieux de continuer à
supprimer les emplois dans les consulats
pour les déployer ensuite à Paris ou à
Nantes les consulats sont aussi les
portes d'entrée pour ceux qui souhaitent
se rendre en France mais qui a l'accueil
il reçoivent-ils aujourd'hui lors de mes
déplacements je constate dans tous les
consulats qu'ils sont peut-être en
situation de gestion de crise permanente
alimentée par les sous effectifs
chroniques dans tous les services et
plus particulièrement le service des
visas
la création du 18 TP au sein du réseau
consulaire dont 7 en administration
centrale et 11 à l'étranger et de toute
évidence très insuffisante
l'augmentation des délais de prise de
rendez-vous engendrer la création de
plateforme privée pour pallier les
carences de l'État ou pire l'apparition
de trafic illégaux de vente de
rendez-vous qui coûte jusqu'à 500 € pour
des personnes tellement désespérées
qu'il paye pour un service normalement
gratuit à cela c'est ajouter une
politique de réduction drastique des
visas en Afrique du Nord affectant
majoritairement des publics francophones
et francophiles au lieu d'une politique
d'accueil que l'on attend de notre pays
nous en faisons un instrument
sécuritaire dommageable pour nos propres
intérêts je voudrais illustrer par deux
exemples le premier lors de mon
déplacement à Agadir j'ai appris par le
wali que la France avait perdu au profit
de l'Autriche le projet de construction
du téléphérique après avoir refusé le
visa de l'investisseur marocain qui
devait venir signer le contrat à Paris
que les Autrichiens lui ont prestement
accordé le second l'étudiant tunisien
formé dans un au lycée français à qui
nous avons refusé un visa et qui est
parti faire ses études supérieures au
Canada conservera sans doute comme
beaucoup d'autres certaines rancœurs
envers notre pays suite à ce refus que
beaucoup vivent comme une humiliation à
la star de cette politique qui ternit
l'image de notre pays à l'étranger la
réforme de la haute fonction publique
abîme notre diplomatie professionnelle
alors où les grands bouleversements
géopolitiques requièrent la plus grande
expertise
après avoir imposé cette réforme son
concertation pourquoi ne pas utiliser
les états généraux de la diplomatie pour
présenter un projet de loi d'orientation
et de programmation du ministère de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
j'aimerais maintenant parler du deuxième
pilier de notre présence à l'étranger
notre réseau éducatif et culturel en
2018 le président de la République
demandait à l'Agence pour l'enseignement
français à l'étranger de doubler le
nombre d'élèves en un temps record et ce
sont moyen ni professeur supplémentaire
et sans ouverture de classe puisque son
développement est toujours entravé par
son incapacité à emprunter soit on croit
au miracle soit c'est annonce cache une
volonté de privatisation du réseau à
marche forcée qui s'appuie sur le
développement des établissements
partenaires on atteste l'amendement que
vous avez retenu par le biais de
l'article 49-3 et dont nous demandons la
suppression ce qui défendent ce tournant
libéral devrait se souvenir qu'en pleine
pandémie notre réseau a tenu le choc
grâce notamment à la puissance publique
et qu'il demeure unique au monde
puisqu’il est construit autour d'un
noyau d'établissement en gestion direct
et conventionnée qui porte en eux la
philosophie de l'école publique
française dont la mission est de
défendre ses valeurs à travers
l'enseignement de notre langue
les 30 millions d'euros prévus pour
l'agence en 2023 ne compenseront pas la
suppression des 33 millions d'euros
subis en 2017 c'est tous de crédit très
attendue par la communauté éducative est
en fait un trompe l'oeil en effet 13
millions d'euros financeront
l'augmentation du point d'indice 7
millions d'euros financeront la moitié
du surcoût lié à la mise en place du
nouveau statut pour les personnels
détachés 10 millions d'euros restant
seront fléchés vers les établissements
scolaires au Liban principalement gérés
par la Mission laïque française que
reste-t-il alors pour soutenir les
rémunérations de nos personnels dans le
pouvoir d'achat est impacté par
l'inflation et par des taux de change
très défavorables dans certains pays et
pour nous établissements qui accumulent
les difficultés nombre d’entre eux
souffrent d'un manque de trésorerie les
contraignant à augmenter les frais de
scolarité peut donc toujours plus sur
les familles
alors que l'école de la République doit
être accessible à tous de nombreuses
familles notamment des classes moyennes
sont impactées par la crise la dotation
allouée aux bourses scolaires est en
augmentation de 11% mais elle revient en
réalité à son niveau de 2021 la
conjugaison de l'augmentation du nombre
d'élèves et de la crise économique
prolongée engendre de fait une
augmentation des demandeurs de bourse
dans nos établissements nous demandons
donc une augmentation de l'enveloppe
afin d'assurer la mixité sociale
préserver l'attractivité de notre réseau
et répondre à tous les besoins il en va
de même pour nous établissements
culturels dans les ressources propres
ont été réduites par les confinements
leur stabilisation budgétaire témoignent
d'un manque d'ambition pour notre
diplomatie culturelle comment atteindre
l'objectif fixé par le chef de l'État
celui d'ouvrir 10 nouvelles alliances
françaises chaque année son moyen
supplémentaires nos instituts français
eux aussi aurait mérité un soutien alors
qu'il continue à souffrir sur le terrain
d'une part ils ont su se moderniser
grâce à l'ouverture du cours en ligne
ils sont aujourd'hui fortement
concurrencés par nouveaux organismes
d'autre part la suppression des postes
de directeur des instituts français
comme par exemple à Fès dont j'ai Agadir
oblige nos consultes généraux à exercer
à plein temps de métiers différents et
on voit un message plutôt négatif quant
à la place que nous réservons à la
culture dans ce pays encore très
francophiles
si nous saluons que les crédits soient
alloués à la communication du ministère
absolument essentiel notamment sur le
continent africain nous ne pouvons que
regretter que notre audiovisuel
extérieur ne soit pas plus soutenue face
à une concurrence internationale accrue
enfin notre développement économique
s'appuie sur un réseau formidable
d'acteurs notre équipe France composée
de la souffrance des conseillers du
commerce extérieur des chambres de
commerce internationales et de business
France ne doit pas être oublié en effet
nous entrepreneurs français apportent un
soutien aux exportations françaises vers
leur pays de résidence et beaucoup
d'artisans développent des savoir-faire
français localement qui renforcent
l'image plutôt positive dont bénéficie
notre pays comme dans bien d'autres
domaines nous possédons les acteurs et
les outils il ne faut pas hésiter de
donner les moyens de leur donner les
moyens d'être à la hauteur de notre
ambition collective pour conclure nous
espérions que ce budget 2023 apporte le
changement radical de politique publique
que nous avions espéré notamment après
votre audition en commission il est vrai
que nous devrions nous féliciter de ne
pas avoir des crédits en baisse et
chaque euro et chaque poste
supplémentaire est évidemment bienvenue
c'est pourquoi nous ne nous opposerons
pas à ce budget mais entendez dans notre
position notre volonté de voir les
crédits de ce grand ministère renforcé
afin de donner à celles et ceux qui le
font vivre les moyens de réussir dans
leur mission respectives et je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant au président Pierre
Laurent pour le groupe CRCE pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en cette période de
résurgence des conflits sur le continent
européen et d'aggravation des crises de
tous ordres au niveau mondial la France
se doit de disposer d'une action
extérieure forte d'un programme
ambitieux de solidarité internationale
et d'un réseau diplomatique à la hauteur
de ses ambitions nous accueillons
favorablement l'augmentation des crédits
alloués à la mission action extérieure
de l'État ainsi que l'augmentation du
plafond d'emploi du MAE 206 ETP mais ces
corrections nous savons tous sont loin
de réparer les débats les dégâts subis
sur une longue période par nos moyens
d'action extérieurs
de surcroît l'insuffisance de ses moyens
s'ajoutent la rupture de confiance qu'a
constitué l'entêtement du gouvernement
contre tous y compris le Sénat à mettre
en cause le modèle de recrutement et le
statut de notre corps diplomatique là
aussi les corrections apportées
n'effacent pas tout le cadorcet a connu
en juin une grève sans précédent et cela
laisse des traces dans cette grève avait
révélé l'ampleur du malaise des
personnels à bout un réseau à l'os face
à une explosion du nombre de missions
demandées un recours trop important à
des conditions d'emplois médiocre le
risque de fragilisation de notre qualité
diplomatique reste réelle alors même que
son
excellence est largement salué mais
au-delà de ces remarques budgétaires je
vous consacrer les quelques minutes dont
je dispose à souligner le caractère
stratégique de notre engagement
diplomatique dans la prévention des
conflits
il s'agit bien plus que d'une question
de budgétaire nous ne pouvons pas
seulement préparer la guerre dans ce
monde plein de conviction de convulsions
nous devons mettre au coeur de nos
priorités la prévention de celle-ci et
la recherche en toute circonstance de
solutions diplomatiques politiques
économique des conflits qui menacent la
symétrie des trajectoires sur long terme
des moyens que nous consacrons à nos
moyens militaires et à nos moyens
diplomatiques révèle à nos yeux une
lecture faussée des enjeux
géostratégiques actuels les inégalement
les inégalités mondiales qui explosent
les fractures croissantes les pauvreté
endémiques constituent le terreau
essentiel des conflits face à une
mondialisation hyper concurrentielle qui
mine les solidarités et génèrent des
insécurités globales alimentaires
sanitaires migratoires sociales
énergétiques
nous devons engager une stratégie de
sécurité humaine globale sans laquelle
l'arme militaire et non seulement
impuissante mais bien souvent
génératrice de chaos supplémentaires la
diplomatie doit être la pièce maîtresse
de notre stratégie de promotion d'une
paie mondiale globale je prends quelques
exemples d'actualité la guerre en
Ukraine je ne reviens pas sur les
sous-estimations les aveuglements les
échecs successifs qui ont conduit par
exemple à négliger les accords de Minsk
comme plus globalement d'ailleurs la
piste d'une renégociation des accords de
sécurité collective en Europe après la
chute du mur de Berlin mais pour
maintenir seulement à l'actualité aux
déclarations du président de la
République ce week-end il déclare à
propos des solutions politiques qu'il
faudra tôt ou tard explorer je le cite
il y a 10 000 formules différentes des
régions plus décentralisées comme prévu
par les accords de Minsk avec
reconnaissance par exemple de la
co-officialité de la langue russe des
territoires sous protection
internationale des formules
d'autodétermination trois petits points
fin de citation comment être utile à ce
travail d'exploit d'exploration sans un
réseau diplomatique solide deuxième
exemple l'échec de la cop27 elle est
dramatique et elle porte en germe nombre
de conflits à venir générés par les
effets des dérèglements climatiques
faisons-nous des cops un objectif de
sécurité stratégique et alors si oui
avec quels moyens diplomatique
supplémentaire pour ne pas aller de Coop
en coop en échec d'échecs en échec
troisième exemple l'échec de barkhane
quelle conclusion en tirons-nous et pas
seulement au plan militaire car l'échec
est d'abord politique et géostratégique
qui redéfinira nos relations avec les
pays du Sahel autrement qu'on
s'enfonçant dans les ruptures actuelles
dont l'extinction de notre APD au Mali
est ainsi triste exemple qui sinon un
réseau diplomatique renforcé et redéfini
dans ses missions
je pourrais multiplier les exemples rien
ne se construira de sérieux en matière
de sécurité collective sans la relance
de puissants efforts politiques et
diplomatique relançant les inévis les
initiatives internationales de la France
ont tout domaine
pour la solution politique au conflit
mais aussi et surtout pour en dire
éradiquer les racines pour un nouvel
ordre économique pour une transition
climatique juste pour la sécurité
alimentaire pour les droits des femmes
pour le respect d'un droit international
qui ne soit plus régie par le de poids
et le deux mesures c'est pour ça que
nous considérons que le relèvement des
moyens est encore bien trop faible et
que je le répète il devrait être la
priorité stratégique de notre politique
de sécurité mondiale c'est pour toutes
ces raisons que nous ne pourrons voter
pour ce budget mais dans votre contre
exprimera surtout une exigence se hisser
au plus vite au niveau des besoins de
diplomatie
la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Olivier Cadic pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la présidence
française de l'Union européenne a été
une grande réussite au premier semestre
grâce aux professionnels et à
l'engagement de nos diplomates que je
veux saluer dès le début de mon propos
la France dispose du troisième réseau
diplomatique mondial celui-ci avait
perdu 50% de ses effectifs en 30 ans
Jean-Yves Le Drillon a eu raison de
mettre un coup d'arrêt à la baisse
continue des moyens du cadorset avec la
création de 106 au TP une première
depuis 1993 vous engagez madame la
ministre un nouvel élan dont nous nous
réjouissons et qui se traduit par une
hausse décris des crédits de l'action
extérieur de l'État la réforme de la
haute fonction publique appliquée au
corps diplomatique à inciter le
président de la République à organiser
des états généraux de la diplomatie la
semaine dernière notre commission a
rencontré l'ambassadeur Jérôme bonafon
rapporteur général des États généraux et
l'équipe qui l'accompagne la
modernisation des ressources humaines du
Quai d'Orsay constitue le grand enjeu de
cette réflexion
l'évolution des missions et des métiers
diplomatiques et consulaires envisagés
m'apparaît encourageante concernant le
programme 185 je veux répondre aux
détracteurs de l'ambition présidentielle
de doubler la taille du réseau de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
d'ici à 2030 en 1990 lors de la création
de l'AFE le réseau comptait 499 écoles
30 ans plus tard on en comptait plus que
470 lorsque Emmanuel Macron a partagé sa
volonté de développer le réseau en 2018
la EFE n'avait toujours pas réussi à
retrouver son nombre d'origine le nouvel
élan porté par le gouvernement a permis
de passer de 495 à 560 écoles françaises
à l'étranger en quatre ans cet
historique
mais comme je l'avais anticipé à cette
tribune il y a deux ans la gouvernance
actuelle du réseau ne permet pas
d'obtenir la croissance nécessaire en
nombre d'élèves pour respecter
l'objectif présidentiel comme l'ont
souligné les rapporteurs l'a EFE se
trouve en conflit d'intérêt il lui est
demandé de développer un réseau destiné
à faire concurrence au 68 établissements
qu'elle administrent en gestion directe
pour sortir de cette injonction
contradictoire il faudrait transférer la
gouvernance des EGD à un autre opérateur
à l'image de la MLF et que l'AEFE se
consacre exclusivement au développement
du réseau afin de libérer sa croissance
les 498 écoles privées mériteraient
d'ailleurs d'être auditionné par les
rapporteurs du programme
185 car qui n'entend qu'un son n'entend
qu'une cloche à l'heure de la Coupe du
Monde madame la ministre je serai
curieux que l'on m'explique comment il
est possible d'être à la fois joueur et
arbitre dans une compétition dans le
programme 151 Français de l'étranger et
à faire consulaire les consulats ne
devraient pas être vu comme des
structures de coûts mais plutôt comme
des structures de service qu'il convient
de développer une mission d'information
sur la politique des visas a été menée
conjointement par les débuts des MJ
d'algérable et sirasila elle a démontré
l'inadéquation observée entre le nombre
d'agents disponibles et le volume à
traiter retard refus inexplicable
frustration légitime abîme inutilement
la relation avec le pays d'accueil un
agent du service visa produit 4 fois
plus de revenus que son coût Londres et
Abidjan collecte 7 millions d'euros
chacun cette année il est prévu 1,7
millions d'euros dans le 151 pour faire
face au recours contre les refus de visa
ne pourrions-nous pas suggérer à Bercy
de mettre le nombre d'agents visa en
corrélation avec le montant de recettes
collectées comme dans une entreprise je
veux rendre hommage à nos élus des
Français de l'étranger engagés en
matière de solidarité et à la Fédération
internationale des accueils français et
francophones d'expatriés la FIAF reconnu
d'utilité publique le mois dernier les
acteurs qui se sont mobilisés en faveur
des réfugiés Ukrainiens comme j'ai pu
l'observer avec l'uefe et la french tech
en Pologne et Roumanie méritent tout
autant d'être salués concernant enfin le
programme 105 qui regroupe les moyens de
l'action diplomatique de la France j'ai
pu constater les effets positifs de la
hausse des contributions volontaires de
la France aux organisations
internationales lors de la visite de la
délégation parlementaire que je
conduisais début novembre à l'ONU un
rapport sénatorial publié début 2022 a
rappelé leur caractère stratégique ces
efforts budgétaires sont poursuivis en
2023 comme la soulignée notre collègue
André gatelin cela n'a pas été écrit par
certains collègues si j'en juge par les
amendements qui prétendent les diminuer
c'est la place de la France dans le
monde chers au général de Gaulle qui se
joue pourtant là les débats permettront
de leur rappeler que l'influence ne se
paye pas qu'en mot la première ministre
Elisabeth borne appelé les ambassadeurs
à renforcer leur relation avec les élus
des Français d'étrangers et fait une
priorité de la simplification de la vie
de nos compatriotes à l'étranger je l'en
remercie le groupe Union centriste
votera la mission action extérieure de
l'État je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant
monsieur André guillaule pour le groupe
RDSE pour 5 minutes
merci président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues pouvons-nous
sérieusement aborder la discussion sur
les programmes 185 et 105 de la mission
extérieure de l'État en égrénant
seulement chiffre avis et opinion et de
faire comme si la guerre ne bouscu les
pas les équilibres que nous espérions
stables et consolidés en Europe depuis
la dernière guerre mondiale
cette agression doit nous inciter à la
prudence et à la modestie et à la
vigilance
et après la pandémie l'agression russe
impose une nouvelle fois à l'Union
européenne un devoir de solidarité
il n'est pas question pour nosyguardes
de faire au profil bas ou pire de
baisser la garde bien au contraire mes
chers collègues nous entendons les
réserves par le programme 185 les
conclusions des rapporteurs soulignent
que les 13 milliards d'augmentation de
l'enveloppe budgétaire consacré à la
diplomatie culturelle et d'influence ne
sont pas à la hauteur des ambitions
affichées par l'exécutif sans être
adepte du toujours plus le groupe RDSE
est bien conscient des effets de
l'inflation qui restent bien plus dures
hors de nos frontières que dans
l'Hexagone la compensé intégralement
serait une prouesse puisque cela
supposerait une adaptation pays par pays
néanmoins les 2% de hausse du budget
alloués au programme 185 de montant de
744 millions d'euros permettent à minima
de maintenir le cap alors que la
récession menace et ce n'est pas
négligeable
c'est bien pour cela que nous ne pouvons
pas nous réduire à des objectifs
volontaristes affichés par exécutif à
des vœux pieux voire des incantations
mes chers collègues le toujours plus qui
est parfois de mise dans les discussions
budgétaires et souvent de façon commode
d'avoir bonne conscience
de même la critique acceptable quand
elle est quand elle sait être juste et
raisonnable se révèle quelquefois veines
quand elle est systématique
souvent elle occulte des avancées
positives que des perspectives
végétaires permettront de concrétiser et
les lignes tracées pour 2023 sans être
flamboyante on l'immense mérite d'être
pragmatique ainsi les deux tiers des 30
millions supplémentaires octroyés à
l'Agence pour l'Enseignement de français
à l'étranger financeront la hausse du
point d'indice des enseignants et
compenseront en partie la mise en place
du nouveau statut de détaché et les 10
millions finançants le soutient au
réseau d'enseignement du français au
Liban sont bien plus qu'un heureux coup
de pouce dans cette dans ce pays
fracturé je ne cache pas que si je
montrerai plus sévère avec la stratégie
bienvenue en France destiné à l'accueil
des étudiants étrangers elle reste bien
timide et souffre de la comparaison qui
peut être dressée avec l'initiative
prise outre-rein la France était au
quatrièmement des pays d'accueil en 2015
elle est aujourd'hui 7e
le consacrons 64 millions affectés au
bourse étudiante alors que le budget est
trois fois supérieur en Allemagne et de
266 millions d'euros pour l'Australie ce
n'est pas acceptable et j'ose espérer
qui ne s'agissent pas de rétrécissement
de nos horizons comme si nous devions
remplacer le phare des lumières qui
rayonnaient sur le monde par la pas le
lueur des tourments nationalistes cette
situation impose la modestie
c'est sans doute là le maillon faible de
cette politique car c'est bien
accueillant et un format des élites de
demain que nous pouvons préparer notre
influence future et durable notre
attaque attractivité ne se résume pas un
déroulement d'un tapis rouge pour les
entreprises étrangères porteuses de
capitaux elle passe aussi par un patient
et discret de travail d'influence
d'accueil et de formation je tenais
rappeler ces quelques chiffres avant
d’aborder le programme 105 qui est une
priorité de la mission de l'action
extérieure de l'État ça progression de
6,6% traduit une volonté politique qui
nous faut saluer les forêts réelles il
permettra pour la première fois depuis
1993 de créer 106 emplois en temps plein
là aussi les esprits chagrins métro en
avant les 3000 postes perdus depuis 2007
laissons-les se chagriner et avec la
création nette d'emploi félicit turnout
de ce changement de paradigme
souvenons-nous que les personnels animal
au troisième réseau diplomatique mondial
ont été sur le pont lors de la pandémie
favorisant le rapatriement de 370
de nous ressortissants ils ont aussi
facilité l'évacuation de 3000 personnes
d'Afghanistan pays plongé dans un
obscurantisme accablant si nous
n'ignorons pas les interrogations liées
à la politique immobilière qui nous ont
fait l'objet de propositions sérieuses
de notre commission sénatoriale
n'hésitez pas à évoquer aussi le sujet
Pineux de la spécificité des parcours
des diplomates mis en cause avec la
disparition de l'École nationale
d'administration comme vous tous mes
chers collègues nous avons été sensibles
aux inquiétudes provoquées par
l'application de la réforme de
l'encadrement supérieur de l'État au
ministère des Affaires étrangères le
groupe RDSE se félicite que le dialogue
est permis de lancer les États généraux
d'un diplomatie qui devrait favoriser
nous le souhaitons un enrichissement de
ces mesures votées au-delà de ces
réserves le groupe RDSE votera les
crédits de la mission je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant au président Christian Cambon
pour les républicains pour 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
c'est le président madame la ministre
sur les rapporteurs mes chers collègues
demain la diplomatie sera plus
nécessaire que jamais ce constat nourrit
par l'inquiétante marche du monde voilà
déjà longtemps que nous le faisons mais
l'année écoulée loin de l'infirmer aura
néanmoins constitué une rupture un
basculement accéléré vers une nouvelle
ère elle aura fait de notre conviction
une évidence le réveil des ambitions
impérialistes et désormais acté le
recours à la force désinhibé et les
quatre et les cadres internationaux
contestés une nouvelle géographie des
tensions et des rapports de force se
dessine amplifiées par les défis de
notre temps qu'ils soient climatique
énergétique alimentaire ou démographique
notre débat d'aujourd'hui a permis de
rappeler que c'est précisément quand le
monde devient plus instable plus
imprévisible plus dangereux aussi
que la mission de nos diplomates devient
sans doute plus essentielle encore
dans le brouillard du nouveau désordre
mondial ils sont à la fois les
éclaireurs et les portes voies de notre
pays et je souhaite ici au nom de notre
groupe et aussi de notre commission si
vous le permettez le rendre un hommage
particulier nos diplomates méritent donc
les moyens à la hauteur de la tâche qui
leur incombe
ce qui relève de la mission action
extérieure de l'État progresseront de
5,2% en 2023 et s'établiront à 3
milliards 2 naturellement nous nous en
réjouissons et nous vous remercions
Madame la ministre d'avoir obtenu cette
avancé tout à fait nouvelle mais il ne
suffit pas d'approuver ces crédits par
ailleurs modeste au regard d'autres
ministères nous devons surtout nous
interroger sur les conséquences pour
notre politique étrangère de la montée
des périls et de l'essoufflement du
multilatéralisme car l'agression russe
en Ukraine a agi comme le révélateur du
nouvel État des relations
internationales bien sûr le courage
admirable et la détermination de la
nation
ukrainienne comme d'ailleurs la
contestation populaire en Iran ou en
Chine tout ceci ébranle les certitudes
de ceux qui annonçaient déjà le triomphe
des régimes autoritaires sur les
démocraties
mais un constat s'impose néanmoins les
autocrates quel que soit leur obédience
ne célèbre plus seulement la primauté de
la force sur la droite il le met il la
met en pratique le 24 février fut la
violente affirmation de cette tendance
de fond qui nous questionne profondément
quelle conclusion devons-nous en tirer
pour notre pays et pour notre diplomatie
les formats doivent-ils être adaptés la
France à entrepris de concentrer ces
personnels vers les zones de croissance
en indopacifique doit-elle poursuivre
dans cette voie dans quelles conditions
et ne doit-elle pas d'abord réexaminer
ses forces en Europe
en quelques semaines la guerre en
Ukraine a balayé nos vieilles certitudes
et mis un coup d'accélérateur aux
recomposition géopolitiques qui Couvet
les exemples n'en manquent pas hier
l'adhésion de la Suède et de la Finlande
à l'OTAN était inimaginable aujourd'hui
elle est quasimentée la Russie est
profondément et durablement éloignée de
l'Europe pour se rapprocher de la Chine
une Chine qui tire d'ailleurs
consciencieusement tous les
enseignements de cette guerre impliquant
les pays occidentaux mais une Chine dont
les plans sont aussi contrarié par les
déboires de son partenaire russe qui
s'enfer dans son isolement prenons garde
toutefois la condamnation de Moscou
n'est pas unanime loin s'en fout c'est
une autre des leçons de la guerre en
Ukraine qu'il faut regarder en face le
temps où les positions occidentales
donnaient le la aux relations
internationales ce temps-là est bien
révolu les positions du G77 exprime la
réticence et parfois même le refus de
soutenir les missions occidentales
condamnant l'invasion russe la position
de l'Inde alliée stratégique et amie
nous interpelle également l'Inde
regrette que cette guerre affaiblisse
son allié russe en Asie elle déplore les
retards de livraison d'armement russe
mais elle tire aussi partie de
l'affrontement en achetant en quantité
impétrole russe à prix cassé enfin
l'humanité se montre toujours incapable
d'apporter une réponse globale au
changement climatique quelle meilleure
illustration de l'affaiblissement du
multilatéralisme les opinions publiques
se mobilisent les étages sont jugés
responsables et de plus en plus souvent
condamné par la justice et pourtant la
cop27 naguère convaincu le fond sur les
pertes et préjudices reste à construire
et faute d'élan il a semblé nécessaire
d'annoncer un sommet à Paris en 2023
avant la prochaine COP vous nous direz
madame la ministre vers quelle
perspective nous allons
alors dans cette en trou plus que jamais
la France a besoin d'une diplomatie
forte d'abord pour tenir son rang bien
sûr nous sommes un état doté un État
membre de permanent du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies un état
disposant du troisième réseau
diplomatique au monde membre fondateur
de l'Union européenne la France a un
positionnement géographique stratégique
au cœur de l'Europe qui fait d'elle un
trait d'union entre les pays du Nord et
le bassin méditerranéen tout ceci nous
oblige et nous donne une responsabilité
particulière la responsabilité de tenir
le positionnement singulier qui a
toujours été celui de notre pays nous
sommes tout à la fois un allié loyal
fiable et efficace au sein de l'OTAN et
promoteur en même temps de l'autonomie
stratégique européenne sachant cultiver
cette position équilibrée la France
parle à tout le monde sans jamais renier
ses valeurs et nous en avons fait
l'expérience commune madame la ministre
séjour dernier aux états
la France répond au désir de France que
les sénateurs constatent dans toute leur
mission à l'étranger face à tous ces
enjeux le PLF 2023 amorce la fin de
l'irlintement mais les temps
d'appauvrissement de notre diplomatie
ont tant duré que cela ne peut être
qu'une première étape certes la pression
des personnels connaît un réel coup
d'arrêt avec 106 et TP créés c'est un
début c'est encore trop peu quand on les
compare aux 3000 postes que votre
département a perdu depuis 2007 et
surtout on ne sait toujours pas comment
ceci seront répartis vous nous éclairez
sur ce point on nous annonce un
renforcement des capacités d'analyse
politique et des implantations dans
l'immense Indo-Pacifique le faudrait-il
pas toutefois concentrer ses moyens sur
une politique en particulier pour
garantir l'impact de l'effort consenti
je pense notamment au renforcement des
équipes de nos consulats qui ont tant
souffert des restrictions budgétaires
passées n'oublions pas ils sont le
guichet unique pour nos concitoyens
vivants hors de France ils le sont aussi
pour les étrangers qui souhaitent s'y
rendre le traitement des demandes de
visa c'est donc la première étape d'une
politique migratoire plus efficace à ce
titre la façon dont on a créé une
différence d'entraînement de traitement
avec l'Algérie et le Maroc en matière de
visa continue à poser problème même si
des évolutions sont en cours
le PLF doit être aussi un moment de
clarification pour nos compatriotes la
France a plus que jamais besoin de
diplomates et de moyens pour défendre
ses intérêts dans un monde devenu plus
dangereux plus difficile à anticiper et
à comprendre un monde sur lequel nos
leviers d'action pourraient si l'on y
prend pas garde perdre de leur
efficacité pour toutes ces raisons le
Sénat attend des états généraux de la
diplomatie qu'il conforte le corps
diplomatique lui qui était si meurtri
par la réforme qui le vise un corps
diplomatique auquel nous rendons et
s'est mérités régulièrement un hommage
appuyé ne serait-ce que pour leur action
en faveur du rapatriement de nos
compatriotes pendant la pandémie
l'évacuation de Kaboul ou la gestion du
dossier nucléaire iranien
c'est très forme vous le savez c'est
très forme du corps diplomatique a
soulevé beaucoup de stylités contre
elles elle a soulevé aussi bien des
moqueries de nos compétiteurs
stratégiques et parfois la perpétuité de
nos alliés qui au contraire renforcent
dans le même temps leur diplomatie
professionnelle
si le Parlement avait eu droit au
chapitre peut être aurions-nous éviter
ou en tous les cas à moins de riz la
grève des personnels du Quai d'Orsay
massivement suivis en juin dernier
c'était la première depuis deux
décennies c'est dire le ressentiment de
nos diplomates c'est un signal pour nous
tous alors il faut maintenant appuyer
apaiser ce trouble et non pas l'appuyer
apaiser se trouve et trouver malgré tout
les voies et moyens pour conforter notre
outil diplomatique les 8 recommandations
faites par nos rapporteurs au Sénat
André vallignier et Jean-Pierre
Grand Pardon excusez-moi pour lui c'est
la fatigue du décalage les 8
recommandations faites par le Sénat vous
offre plusieurs pistes pour tenter de
corriger les effets de bord de la
réforme je n'en citerai qu'une très
importante nous avons proposé la
consultation des commissions des
affaires étrangères du Parlement avant
la nomination au poste d'ambassadeurs
les plus importants par exemple dans les
grands pays européens à Pékin Washington
ou au Conseil de sécurité des Nations
unies il s'agirait en fait d'étendre le
dispositif de l'article 13 de la
Constitution qui prévoit déjà la
consultation de commission parlementaire
compétente pour une cinquantaine de
postes d'importance dans d'autres
domaines ce serait un signal
d'hommage à l'action du Parlement dans
ce domaine en tout état de cause soyez
assurés que le Sénat restera vigilant et
mobilisé sur ce sujet fondamental pour
notre pays nous participerons à vos
travaux nous vous tendons la main mais
pour essayer de faire en sorte que
l'apaisement suivre l'orage madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le groupe
les républicains votera bien évidemment
le budget de des actions extérieure de
l'État suivant ce point les
recommandations de nos rapporteurs mais
nous sommes conscients que les temps qui
viennent seront lourdes menaces et nous
aurons besoin d'y faire face pour y
faire face nous aurons besoin d'un outil
diplomatique conforté dans ses missions
et dans ses moyens vous le savez nous le
savons tous la voie de la France est
attendue donnons-lui les moyens d'être
entendus je vous remercie merci monsieur
le Président la parole est maintenant
Monsieur Joël guerriot pour le groupe
les indépendants pour 5 minutes
ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues après avoir connu une
pandémie le monde connaît à présent de
grandes tensions le 24 février dernier
la Russie envahi l'Ukraine ramenant la
guerre sur notre continent et ce conflit
et l'affaire bien sûr de tous les
Européens en plus de mettre en cause la
liberté d'un peuple il détériore
significativement des conditions de
notre prospérité dans ce contexte
troublé et en sachant que les périodes
difficiles nous attendent comme la
rappeler très justement le président de
notre commission il est essentiel que la
France puisse faire entendre sa voix
elle a fait lors de la crise de
sanitaire en contribuant à la mise en
place d'un emprunt commun au sein de
l'Union ce mécanisme m'a permis de
donner corps à la solidarité européenne
et à constituer un véritable avancée il
y impacte 20 fois séculaire entre la
grandeur de la France et la liberté du
monde nous disait le Général de Gaulle
notre pays est en effet porteur d'un
idéal et de valeur qui ont plus d'une
fois influencer le cours de notre
histoire la liberté bien sûr mais
également l'égalité famome le droit des
peuples à disposer de même ou encore le
destin commun des peuples européens il
faut donc préserver notre capacité la
capacité d'un pays à se faire entendre
d'autres pays investissent massivement
dans leur diplomatie et se donne ainsi
les moyens de gagner une influence et de
peser sur le cours des événements
internationaux la France ne doit pas se
laisser distancer et crédits que nous
examinons aujourd'hui contribue à
maintenir notre influence et revêtent
donc une importance toute particulière à
cet égard Nous nous réjouissons que les
dépenses de personnel de la mission
souhaitant hausse la hausse des prix
globales explique en partie cette
augmentation le contexte inflationniste
n'épargnant pas notre pays ni aucun
autre pays il fait progresser le coût
des indemnités de résidence à l'étranger
il le doit cependant pas masquer le
renforcement des effectifs 106
équivalentes en plein supplémentaires
sont prévus pour 2023 ces personnels
permettent à la France de savoir avec
précision ce qui se passe à l'étranger
d'analyser de comprendre d'anticiper et
d'agir en conséquence il contribue
également à faire rayonner notre nos
valeurs nos entreprises la France
dispose de l'un des réseaux
diplomatiques les plus étendus au monde
c'est là un atout qu'il faut préserver
dans un monde où la désinformation est
une arme redoutable en affectant les
réseaux sociaux et il est important d'y
voir clair par nous-mêmes la
représentation du paiement diplomatique
est essentielle pour s'évaluer pour
s'assurer d'une évaluation objective des
situations à travers le monde il nous
faudra également continuer d'investir
dans le parc immobilier le contexte
économique pèse sur ces budgets comme
sur ce consacré aux personnel
l'inflation Hérode l'ensemble des
crédits la remontée du cours de dollar
s'aggrave encore aggrave encore cette
situation en raison de la position
dominante de cette monnaie en
internationale
ces augmentations de crédit se
justifient amplement l'influence fait en
pleinement partie des objectifs
stratégiques de la France plus que le
rayonnement de notre pays cette capacité
doit nous permettre de renforcer notre
poids sur la scène internationale la
diplomatie en tant de crise et a
fortiori en temps de guerre peut sembler
accessoire à certains il en est rien
c'est à travers elle que les alliances
nous et que les rapports de force
évoluent il faut pour cela y consacrer
des moyens suffisants la Chine de son
côté ne s'y trompe pas elle consacre
ainsi plus de 10 milliards de dollars
par an au développement de son influence
la France et ses partenaires européens
font face à de graves défis militaires
économiques mais aussi écologique ces
défis nous place devant une alternative
y répondre collectivement ou bien céder
à l'opportunisme de court terme aucun
État européen ne peut parvenir seul à la
dépendance stratégique c'est par la
coopération et la diplomatie que nous
pourrons développer des solutions de
long terme conformes à nos intérêts
communs le budget 2023 maintient
globalement les fonds consacrés à ses
capacités même s'il ne les accroît pas
autant que nous le souhaiterions le
groupe Les Indépendants votera en faveur
les crédits de cette mission merci merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
monsieur Pierre-Antoine Lévy pour le
groupe Union centriste pour 3 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci pour votre soutien monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues le budget consacré à la
diplomatie culturelle et d'influence en
2023 augmente de 40 millions d'euros à
périmètre constant pour un total de 671
millions d'euros les moyens de l'Agence
pour l'enseignement du français à
l'étranger sont renforcés à hauteur de
30 millions d'euros tandis que ceux
consacrer au réseau de coopération
culturelle sont stables comme cela a été
rappelé par les orateurs précédents en
mars 2018 le président de la République
fixé pour objectif au réseau
d'enseignement ou du français à
l'étranger le doublement de ces
effectifs à l'horizon 2030 soit une
cible de 700 000 élèves cela correspond
une croissance moyenne de l'ordre de 7 à
8%. depuis cette annonce c'est malgré la
crise sanitaire qui a deux factures
ralenti le processus de développement le
réseau de l'AFE a gagné 72
établissements et plus de 30 000 élèves
le rythme moyen de croissance annuelle
des effectifs et cependant très en deçà
de celui nécessaire à l'atteinte de
l'objectif présidentiel dans le
calendrier imparti
cette ambition présidentielle sur
notamment à trois enjeux structurels le
premier mais celui des effectifs des
personnels enseignants et de leur
formation question centrale pour
garantir la qualité de l'offre éducative
l'atteinte de la cible de 700000 élèves
suppose 25 000 enseignants
supplémentaires ce qui représente un
besoin de recrutement conséquent sans
enseigner en nombre suffisant et bien
formés le plan ne pourra pas fonctionner
le deuxième enjeu est immobilié pour se
développer et faire face à la
concurrence internationale les
établissements déjà membres du réseau
ont besoin d'améliorer l'état de leur
bâti voire de la grandir si pour les
établissements conventionnés et
partenaires un outil d'accompagnement
existent tel n'est pas le cas pour les
établissements gestion direct qui
éprouvent de grandes difficultés à
financières au projet immobilier
alors de la définition du prochain
schéma pluriannuel de stratégie
immobilière 2023 2027 la BFE évalue le
besoin de financement de l'immobilier
des EGD à 300 millions d'euros sur les 5
prochaines années
le troisième enjeu concerne la
régulation de la croissance du réseau
pour éviter les comportements de
concurrence déloyale entre établissement
anciennement membres et établissement
nouvellement homologué
il faut ajouter à ces enjeux structurels
les crises conjoncturelles auxquelles le
réseau peut être confronté l'invasion de
l'Ukraine a par exemple toucher
directement 5 établissements de la
région la crise inflationniste n'épargne
aucune zone géographique et suicide de
très bien études pour 2023 l'envoler des
prix de fluides chauffage électricité
renchérit directement les coups de
fonctionnement des établissements les
établissements gestion direct du réseau
ont reçu pour consigne de ne pas
répercuter l'entièreté des surcous sur
les familles mais de trouver un
équilibre entre os des droits des
collages et économie de dépenses en 2023
les droits de scolarité devraient en
moyenne augmenter de 8% dans les EGD
dans certains établissements la hausse
pourrait même atteindre 10 voire 12%. ce
qui nourrit de forzink et twitch chez
les parents d'élèves
en conclusion et cela a été dit par mon
collègue Olivier caddy le groupe Union
centriste votera les crédit de la
mission action extérieure de l'État tout
en restant attentif aux difficultés qui
viennent d'être soulevées je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères pour 15
minutes vous avez la parole madame la
ministre
monsieur le Président
non messieurs les rapporteurs je ne
compte point de dames parmi vos
messieurs les rapporteurs et
co-rapporteurs mesdames sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs permettez-moi
tout d'abord de saluer la qualité de vos
interventions successives qui reflète
bien l'intérêt que le Sénat porte au
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères intérêt qui s'est aussi
traduit par un vote favorable au budget
de mon ministère à la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
comme à la commission des finances ce
dont je vous remercie
vous le savez le contexte international
n'a pas été aussi critique et dangereux
depuis longtemps
nous vivons en effet dans un monde en
voie de fracturation un monde plus
brutal plus instable ou les menaces
globales se renforcent et où les crises
se multiplient vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président Cambon
de plus nous voyons que nous intérêts
sont souvent contestés qu'ils soient
politiques ou économiques nous sommes
confrontés à des menaces qui visent nos
ressortissants et nos emprises les
menaces qui se déploient aussi dans le
champ numérique ou informationnel où
nous sommes la cible d'opération de
propagande et de désinformation
cette tendance à ce qu'on a pu appeler
la brutalisation du monde
ne date pas d'hier certes mais elle a
pris une ampleur nouvelle il y a neuf
mois lorsque la Russie a choisi
d'envahir un pays souverain voisin et
ramener la guerre sur le continent
européen en agressant militairement le
crâne
du fait de cette agression des
situations de tension deviennent des
situations de crise énergétiques ou
alimentaire par exemple qui exacerbe les
divisions et risquent de fragmenter plus
encore la scène internationale alors
dans cet environnement stratégique
dégradée la diplomatie est plus que
jamais nécessaire merci à ceux d'entre
vous mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
qu'il avait rappelé une diplomatie
d'action une diplomatie combative une
pharmacie qui pourrait être efficace a
besoin de moyens
ces moyens ce budget nous les fournit en
2023 il devra en effet atteindre 6
milliards 65 en crédit de paiement pour
l'ensemble des missions en augmentation
de 543 millions soit 9 % par rapport à
la loi de finement initiale pour 2022
cette hausse bénéficierait à hauteur de
160 millions supplémentaires à la
mission action extérieure de l'État qui
atteindrait ainsi 3 milliards 218
160 millions supplémentaires c'est une
augmentation substantielle pour un
ministère comme le nôtre
du côté de nos moyens humains alors que
nous effectifs avaient baissé de 30% sur
les deux dernières décennies je dis bien
30% et je ne connais aucun autre
ministère régalien qui est subi une
telle attrition je souhaite insister sur
leur hausse en 2023 pour la première
fois depuis 1993
cette hausse va nous permettre de
disposer de 106 et TP de plus qu'en 2022
je vous l'avais dit et je vous le
confirme la répartition de ces nouveaux
effectifs concernera très
majoritairement la mission action
extérieure de l'État et prioritairement
à l'étranger pour les deux tiers d'entre
eux comme je l'avais annoncé en
commission
grâce aux moyens de la mission action
extérieure de l'État nous pourrons
maintenir un outil diplomatique
universel capable de se déployer partout
dans dans le monde et d'agir dans la
quasi-totalité des organisations
internationales et régionales la France
dispose dois-je le rappeler du 3e réseau
diplomatique mondial avec 163 ambassades
16 représentations permanentes et 90
consulats généraux
cet universalité nous permet d'être
présent partout et nous met en mesure de
parler à tout le monde c'est essentiel
pour promouvoir le dialogue politique
entre état construire des partenariats
et renforcer nos coopérations dans tous
les domaines et à ce propos je
m'autorise une incidence madame la
sénatrice Vogel pour appeler que les
crédits consacrés à la transition
écologique s'examineront dans la mission
être publique au développement donc plus
tard dans notre débat
notre outil universelle est aussi un
atout majeur pour bâtir des coalitions
d'actions dont nous avons besoin pour
agir à l'ONU et dans les organisations
internationales
c'est enfin un outil puissant au service
de nos ressortissants que nous avons
ainsi pu aider partout dans le monde
lors de la pandémie comme on s'en
souvient et comme vous avez bien voulu
le rappeler monsieur sénateur Guillaume
à ce propos permettez-moi également de
revenir sur un point évoqué dans votre
débat évoqué par le rapporteur qui est
celui de la hausse des crédits de
personnels elle est bien évidemment liée
à la création de ces nouveaux postes à
l'étranger dans notre diplomatie a tant
besoin mais elle doit beaucoup également
à l'inflation mondiale supérieure à
celle que nous connaissons en France en
règle générale et à la baisse de l'euro
dans ce contexte de persistance c'est
souvent des raviations de la menace en
Afrique on a encore vu au Burkina Faso
ou bien en Ukraine alors que tout le
pays est touché par les bombes y compris
aujourd'hui même vous l'avez vu les
moyennes nouveaux du programme 105
concerneront d'abord la sécurité
il permettront de sécurité de sécuriser
pardon nous ambassades là où nos agents
sont le plus exposés à des situations de
crise ou d'instabilité nous proposons
d'y consacrer 5 millions d'euros
d'autorisation d'engagement et 3
millions d'euros au crédit de paiement
la progression des crédits du programme
105 bénéficiera à une autre priorité le
numérique nous continuerons à consentir
des investissements soutenus afin
d'améliorer l'efficacité de nos outils
de pallier les inégalités de déploiement
selon les pays et de renforcer la
cybersécurité de notre réseau nous
souhaitons dédié une enveloppe de 52
millions d'euros cette priorité soit une
hausse de 4,4 millions d'euros par
rapport à l'année dernière
la communication stratégique est un
autre enjeu de plus en plus important
qu'elle nous sommes confrontés puisque
nous faisons face à des opérations
hostiles de désinformation de propagande
souvent d'origine russe mais pas
exclusivement je dois le dire qui vise à
attiser un discours anti-français sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment on le voit
en Afrique ou en Europe afin de mieux
lutter contre ces pratiques nous
souhaitons augmenter de 2 millions et
demi d'euros les moyens de la direction
de la communication et de la presse dans
son discours de Toulon le 9 novembre le
président de la République en effet
déclaré et je le cite l'influence sera
désormais une fonction stratégique dotée
de moyens substantiels avec pour sa
déclinaison internationale un rôle
central du ministère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères
enfin autre priorité que je voudrais
mentionner l'éducation l'éducation en
français et à la française avec
566 établissements dans 138 pays et
presque 390000 élèves les EFE poursuivra
son plan de développement avec des
moyens qui seraient si vous l'accepter
renforcés à hauteur de 30 millions
d'euros
permettez-moi d'ajouter que nous
reprenons à bon rythme l'augmentation du
nombre d'élèves après deux années de
covid et deux années de covid qui ont
ralenti l'activité bien sûr ils viennent
fosser les projections
pour poursuivre à bon rythme il faut des
moyens monsieur le rapporteur et comme
cela ne peut se faire par l'emprunt nous
cherchons des solutions via l'impossible
d'utilisation des subventions pour
charges d'investissement
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est priorité s'accompagneront d'une
préoccupation constante qui est celle
d'aider et de protéger les Français de
l'étranger car le Quai d'Orsay est aussi
le grand service public des Français à
l'étranger en 2023 notre action
consulaire portée par le programme 151
pourrait être doté de
141,1 millions d'euros alors que nos
compatriotes sont confrontés
dans de nombreux pays d'ailleurs à des
contextes économiques dégradés ils
pourront continuer de compter sur une
gamme d'aide sociale inégalée chez nos
partenaires
les bourses scolaires destinées aux
enfants français de nos établissements
scolaires retrouveraient leur niveau de
2021 avec un budget de 105,8 millions
d'euros puisque nous solliciterons moins
la soulte et soyez assurés que chaque
enfant qui remplit les critères pour
avoir une bourse la recevra
afin de répondre aux besoinscru de la
Communauté française à l'étranger des
crédits supplémentaires seront
aussi alloués au titre de l'aide sociale
16 milliards de 16 millions de
pardonnez-moi en 2023 soit 1 million de
plus un million de plus par rapport à
l'année 2022 toutes ces aides seront
distribuées évidemment en lien avec les
élus consulaires qui constituent pour
nous un prêt sur l'idée des besoins des
Français d'étrangers et de nos actions
voilà en quelques mots messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs quelques
observations que je voulais faire après
vous avoir entendu et avant que nous
examinions différents amendements je
vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
bien mes chers collègues il est 16h11
normalement la mission de western uni à
17h30 avec la demi-heure supplémentaire
accordée par la commission des finances
c'est donc 18h donc c'est extrêmement
simple à 18h s'il reste trois quatre
amendements on termine si il en reste 10
15 je suspendrais la séance pour voir
avec le commission avec le président de
la commission des finances à quel moment
sera reporté le solde de la mission qui
passera probablement
cette nuit après ou avant les articles
non rattachés
allez j'attaque à l'article 27 est AB
l'amendement
1275 madame Vogel
pas besoin de vous rappeler l'importance
considérable de l'éducation pour les
générations de demain or les Français et
les Français de l'étranger doivent
pouvoir aussi accéder à un enseignement
de qualité à un coût raisonnable le
problème c'est que après correction de
l'inflation le budget dédié à
l'enseignement français étranger a
baissé de 11,5% depuis 2012 et 500
postes ont été supprimés dans nos lycées
les conséquences concrètes de cette
politique ce sont que les Françaises et
les Français de l'étranger voient les
coûts de scolarité exploser il est de
plus en plus d'élèves dans nos
établissements notamment en raison de la
politique du chiffre qui de d'Emmanuel
Macron qui veut doubler le nombre
d'élèves mais proportionnellement de
moins en moins d'enseignants et de
personnels pour s'en occuper ce
désengagement de l'étape profite
évidemment au secteur privé on en fait
le constat partout au sein de notre
réseau or il faut donner excusez-moi
j'essaie d'aller vite pour qu'on finisse
pas cette nuit
à la fée les moyens de fonctionner
autrement que par des os répéter des
frais de scolarité qui frappent les
Françaises de l'étranger en période de
crise je vous propose donc par cet
amendement de revenir au montant qui
était alloué à l'aéfe il y a 10 ans et
d'augmenter de 60 millions d'euros le
budget de l'Agence pour l'enseignement
français à l'étranger merci avis de la
commission
merci monsieur le Président les besoins
sont très importants pour la EFE je
crois que nous ne pouvons pas le nier
ceci dit et pour la première année les
crédits de l'agence augmente de près de
30 millions cette année même si
évidemment des besoins bien supérieurs
peuvent exister mais comme c'est une
année où les crédits augmentent la vie
de la Commission et défavorable pour un
amendement d'abondement supplémentaire
merci avis du gouvernement
ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je suivrai la vie de la
commission je viens de le dire les la
subvention devrait augmenter pour les
feux de 30 millions d'euros par rapport
à la loi de finance initiale 2022 c'est
un effort signification et donc le
soutien de l'État via ce programme est à
la hauteur des enjeux de développement
de l'enseignement du français à
l'étranger ce serait par ailleurs si les
crédits du programme 105 2V être réduit
au profit d'une nouvelle action
ce qui irait à l'encontre de besoin dont
je crois avoir tenté de vous faire
comprendre combien ils étaient
importants merci je mets aux voix le
1275 avec deux avis défavorables qui est
pour
trois amendements
en discussion comme une le 1237 monsieur
Lecomte merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre cet amendement vise à
augmenter les crédits des bourses
scolaires vous avez vu des de l'évoquer
dans votre allocution vous avez évoqué
les critères or nous constatons
qu'aujourd'hui les critères ne sont pas
satisfaisants dans une période
d'hyperinflation dans un certain nombre
de pays de taux de change
particulièrement variable de nombre de
pays où il y a des taux parallèles qui
font en sorte qui qui conduisent à ce
que les taux de chancellerie qui sont
utilisés pour le calcul du barème sont
complètement inadéquats nous constatons
aussi une baisse de l'euro vis-à-vis du
dollar qui à moins de riz les capacités
d'action de l'enveloppe qui est qui
serait voté sans ces 20 millions d'euros
de plus et c'est la raison pour laquelle
madame la ministre nous proposons cette
augmentation et nous souhaitons savoir
comment dans une période
d'hyperinflation avec des taux des taux
de change qui évoluent tout le temps
comment nous pouvons servir des familles
en faisant une photographie de leur
situation au mois d'avril pour l'année
suivante c'est juste impossible et la
question que nous vous posons par cet
amendement c'est comment revoir le
barème des bourses dans cette période
d'hyperinflation et de taux de change
qui sont tout à fait variables c'est le
1225 madame Conway
et reprendre les arguments développés
par mon collègue nous avons simplement
des estimations un petit peu différentes
mais nous sommes tous d'accord sur la
nécessité de l'augmentation de
l'enveloppe des bourses aussi sur la
mise à dispositions et bien d'une aide
pour les familles j'insisteraient aussi
sur l'accent que nous devrions mettre
sur l'aspect social et non pas
simplement comptable des décisions qui
sont prises et bonne décision qui sont
prises dans les conseils consulaires qui
devraient être respectées par la
Commission nationale des bourses merci
Madame Vogel 2273 défendu merci avis de
la commission sur ces trois amendements
merci monsieur le Président cette
question des bourses revient chaque
année elle est évidemment extrêmement
importante et très sensible
la Commission donne un avis défavorable
aux amendements néanmoins j'ai moi-même
évoqué dans mon intervention cette
question des bourses particulièrement
sensible et pour 2023 à la fois du fait
de l'évolution de l'inflation notamment
dans certains pays et d'autre part de
l'épuisement programmé de la soulte de
la EFE donc je pense madame la ministre
que cette question doit pouvoir aussi
revenir dans une loi de finance
rectificative si c'était nécessaire par
rapport à l'évolution de l'inflation
mondiale dans le cours de l'année et
pour l'année prochaine la solution de la
soulte ne sera plus une solution a
priori et cette question du budget des
bourses sera évidemment regardée
attentivement
merci avis du gouvernement Madame le
Ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs deux points
rapides en 2023 le PLF montant de 104,4
millions d'euros pour les bourses
scolaires soit une augmentation de plus
de 10 millions d'euros
10,2 par rapport à 2022 donc on revient
au socle budgétaire deuxième remarque
pour l'année qui vient il reste reliquat
de la soulte qui pourrait s'établir à 7
millions et demi d'euros et ce qui
permettrait l'opérateur de compléter la
dotation versée par le programme 151 si
cela était nécessaire compte tenu du
contexte inflationniste que beaucoup
d'entre vous ont rappelé donc le
gouvernement d'un avis défavorable pour
le budget 2023 sur ses amendements merci
je vais mettre vos voix successivement
les trois amendements qui ont les trois
deux avis défavorables le 1237 qui est
pour
[Musique]
c'est le même vote pour les deux
suivants
même vote même vote
3 amendements à nouveau en discussion
commune le 1242 monsieur chanterelle oui
monsieur le Président Madame les
ministres chers collègues plusieurs
collègues ont évoqué justement la
situation de nos postes consulaires qui
sont sous tension en raison de la baisse
constante des effectifs ces dernières
années ce qui a occasionné et nous en
sommes le témoin puisque nous allons
dans les différents postes consulaires
une réduction une dégradation du service
le personnel n'est pas mis en cause au
contraire ils sont victimes de la
situation d'ailleurs ils ont eu une
forte tension sur les épaules tout au
long de la pandémie son soutien
supplémentaire ce qui occasionne une
dégradation même de la santé du
personnel des burn out des difficultés
finalement rendre le service public
c'est aussi prendre soin des personnes
qui l'administre et je pense qu'il est
fondamental justement d'augmenter de
manière significative les personnels et
c'est pas compliqué j'ai consulté votre
propre ministère pour savoir combien de
personnel ça prendrait pour ne serait-ce
que boucher les trous pour qu'on puisse
avoir un réel service c'est 300 300 et
TP ça correspond à peu près ce que vous
avez supprimé ces dernières années 300
et TP dans le consulaire puisque vous
avez actuellement sans création de poste
qui est prévue sauf qu'il y en a que 11
pour le consulaire c'est une goutte
d'eau c'est 300 postes qui vaut qu'il
faut c'est amendement tout simplement et
vous propose de créer ce que vous avez
supprimé au cours de ces dernières
années pour venir en aide au personnel
consulaires en créant ces 300 postes dès
le budget prochain merci Madame Vogel le
1272 merci monsieur le Président mon
collègue l'a très bien dit notre réseau
consulaire est à l'os et nos agents et
nos agents de partout dans le monde sont
dans l'incapacité même si ils font leur
travail du mieux qu'ils peuvent
d'exercer leurs tâches avec des
conséquences très problématiques sur les
parfois les droits fondamentaux de nos
compatriotes à l'étranger par le même
nous avons déduit que c'est très bien
les sens de TP en plus il y a une
chanterelle l'a dit c'est 11 seulement
dans le réseau consulaire c'est très
bien mais c'est très très loin de ce qui
est nécessaire c'est pour ça que nous
faisons cet amendement pour demander
pour permettre la création de 300 et TP
en plus dans le réseau consulaire qui
est simplement ce dont nous avons besoin
pour permettre l'accès aux services
publics à nos compatriotes à l'étranger
ni plus ni moins merci le 1215 monsieur
le glue merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues nos consulats souffrent
les Français qui vivent à l'étranger ne
parviennent plus à joindre leur consulat
par téléphone c'est impossible prendre
un rendez-vous pour renouveler un
passeport une carte d'identité prend un
temps interminable c'est la réalité de
notre réseau consulaire aujourd'hui et
tous les déplacements à l'étranger nous
avons partout ce témoignage de nos
communautés françaises qui nous disent
nos services consulaires ne fonctionnent
plus comprenez bien que depuis 1993 le
nombre d'agents est en baisse depuis 93
et dans le même temps le nombre de
Français qui vivent à l'étranger
augmente il y a un moment où ça ne
fonctionne plus
cet amendement vise donc à augmenter les
effectifs du service public consulaire
qui fait face à une augmentation des
tâches qui lui sont confiées sans avoir
les moyens de les assumer dans de bonnes
conditions
cela met en péril à la fois la santé des
agents concernés qui pourtant font
preuve d'un dévouement exceptionnel
avec une multiplication des cas de Burn
Out qui nous a qui doit nous alerter
s'agissant de la qualité du service les
délais de traitement des demandes ont
connu une dégradation qui n'est plus
soutenable aujourd'hui il faut donc
redonner de l'oxygène au service public
consulaires et aux agents de qualité qui
le portent dans le projet de loi de
finances on nous parle d'une
augmentation de 18 équivalentes en plein
de 18 agents au regard du nombre
d'incendies de nos services consulaires
à travers le monde cela n'y suffira
absolument pas
merci avis de la commission sur ces
trois amendements
merci à Monsieur le Président en effet
je pense que c'est ce sont nos services
consulaires qui ont le plus
souffert des réductions d'emplois
publics à l'étranger ces dernières
années je crois que chacun le constate
et c'est pour cela qu'il y a trois
amendements qui vont dans le même sens
néanmoins c'est bien dans le budget
proposé pour 2023 qu'il y a une
augmentation des crédits de 15 millions
d'euros pour le programme français de
l'étranger et à faire consulaire et
qu'une partie des graisses de la
centaine de création de postes dans ce
budget pour le mystère et Affaires
étrangères sera destiné au service
consulaire même si je pense que
évidemment cela ne répondra pas à
l'ensemble des besoins enfin il y a une
difficulté qui est plus technique sur
l'amendement en ce enfin sur les
amendements en ce qu'ils allouent des
crédits budgétaires supplémentaires mais
sans l'accompagner dans une modification
des plafonds d'emploi ce qui ne le
rendrait pas les rendraient pas opérant
dans la mise en œuvre de ces crédits
pour augmenter le nombre d'emplois donc
la vie de la commission est défavorable
avez du gouvernement madame la ministre
ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs la
ville gouvernement sera également
défavorable d'abord je voudrais appeler
que cette année nous émettons moins de
visa qu'en 2019 moins de visa qu'en 2019
donc si des tensions apparaissent dans
certains consulats il faut en analyser
les raisons pour voir comment améliorer
des choses parce qu'on ne peut pas dire
qu'il y ait augmentation des tâches
entre 2019 et 2022 et donc c'est sur
cette base que nous verrons quels moyens
qu'elle correctif
seront nécessaires deuxièmement j'ai
annoncé lors de la conférence des
ambassadrices et des ambassadeurs la
création d'un Centre de soutien du
réseau consulaire afin de pouvoir
intervenir là où des tensions se font
ressentir et puis je vais également
examiner en lien avec le ministère de
l'intérieur ce qui peut être amélioré
dans le fonctionnement de nos consulats
merci Monsieur Lecomte brièvement
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
il est absolument essentiel de doter
mieux nos personnels nos consulats en
personnel sur les visas il y a un
certain nombre de postes qui ont des
activités qui sont très soutenues et qui
sont plus en plus compliqués vous me
l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé dans un
courrier la semaine dernière
concernant les passeports l'activité est
particulièrement soutenue par rapport
aux années précédentes et Madame la
Ministre j'attire votre attention sur un
élément c'est la mise en place d'Ethias
l'année prochaine qui va conduire un
certain nombre de binationaux qui n'ont
pas de passeport français et qui ont
l'habitude de venir en Europe à ne plus
pouvoir venir en Europe s'ils n'ont pas
de passeport français nous avons besoin
rien que pour ça d'un plan de
communication et d'un plan dans un
certain nombre de consulats qui doit
être prévu dès maintenant alors que j'ai
le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
le cas et pour cette raison aussi il y a
besoin de moyens complémentaires
attendez moi je veux bien donner la
parole à tous ceux qui la demande mais
si vous demandez tous la parole sur
chaque amendement je vous garantis qu'à
18h vous êtes reporté à minuit allez
monsieur Cadic merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président donc d'ailleurs j'ai été
moi-même assez économe en amendement
pour pouvoir juste dire une chose que
j'apprécie beaucoup le fait que les
sénateurs se soient inquiétés de la
baisse des effectifs
donc au niveau du ministère en rappelant
qu'effectivement c'est pendant 30 ans
que 50% des effectifs ont été baissés
donc venir maintenant réclamer et dire
que à cause de ça il faudrait remettre
plus d'agents et plus d'argent ça part
un petit peu décalé simplement pour dire
que il faut revoir cette organisation
c'est-à-dire que on rentre de l'argent
en prenant les visas et en face de ce
revenu il faut mettre des dépenses il
faut lier comme dans une entreprise les
deux on fait les choses comme si c'était
totalement déconnecté mais quand on a de
revenus et ben en face des clients faut
mettre des gens pour faire le service
voilà c'est ça qu'il faut changer dans
notre système merci allez je mets aux
voix le 1242 avis des favorables qui est
pour
1272 avis des favorables qui pour
qui contre
1215 deux avis défavorables qui pour
quiconque
deux amendements identiques maintenant
le 1233 madame colonel Mouret
sont consacrés à la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments publics
implantés sur le territoire national le
parc immobilier de l'État à l'étranger
n'est pas concerné pourtant lorsque je
fais le tour de nos emprises lors de mes
déplacements à l'étranger je constate
que certains bâtiments sont soit de
véritables passoires thermiques soit ne
sont pas adaptés aux aléas du climat
alors que la hausse du coût de l'énergie
est exponentielle dans la majorité des
pays devient essentiel d'utiliser
davantage les énergies renouvelables et
d'essayer notamment d'éviter les
gaspillages en énergie s'agit donc de
rénover l'ancien mais aussi d'inclure
ces critères dans les plans de
construction actuel ce qui par exemple
n'a pas été le cas dans les nouveaux
bâtiments du lycée français de Tunis
pour faire baisser la facture
énergétique et lutter contre le
changement climatique nous ne pouvons
pas compter uniquement sur les efforts
individuels de nos compatriotes nous
devons être collectivement responsables
et faire les bons choix pour nos
équipements il en va des conditions de
travail de nos personnels et de
l'environnement scolaire de nos enfants
c'est amendement propose d'y consacrer
15 millions d'euros
merci le 1274 madame Vogel merci
monsieur le Président donc c'est
amendement est la reprise d'un
amendement de mes collègues écologistes
à l'Assemblée nationale la France en
effet en retard sur sa politique de
rénovation des bâtiments c'est pas
nouveau un plan de rénovation thermique
des bâtiments publics en métropole pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone ici
200050 a été lancée c'est très loin
d'être suffisant pour faire face à la
catastrophe écologique mais au moins ça
existe sauf que pour tous les bâtiments
français à l'étranger bien c'est pas le
cas 163 ambassades les consulats 19
consulats généraux trois bulots
consulaires et un consulat en Europe et
96 instituts français et évidemment
l'agence de l'enseignement français à
l'étranger je vous propose donc un plan
de 15 millions d'euros pour lancer la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
publics français à l'étranger 15
millions d'euros c'est rien comparé au
nombre d'économies à long terme qui
impliquent ces rénovations rien du tout
ce chiffre de 15 millions d'euros ce
n'est même pas le mien mais c'est une
estimation de la direction des immeubles
et de la logistique du ministère de
l'Europe et des affaires étrangères
c'est donc je pense une proposition
raisonnable que je vous invite à
soutenir je vous remercie merci avis de
la commission sur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président oui deux
amendements identiques pour augmenter
les crédits dédiés à l'amélioration de
la performance énergétique et
environnementale des bâtiments c'est
vrai que dans le cadre de notre contrôle
budgétaire que nous réalisons sur
l'immobilier du ministère nous avons
effectivement été sensibilisés par le
ministère au fait que les besoins
recensés en matière de performance
environnementale se heurter à des
difficultés au plan budgétaires donc
nous pensons que effectivement cet
élément doit s'inscrire dans une
ambition globale et dans dans un plan
global et c'est pour ça que nous
demandons l'avis du Gouvernement sur
cette demande de 15 millions
supplémentaires mais on souhaite surtout
qu'il nous explicite l'ampleur des
besoins budgétaires du ministère et la
manière dont il entend les couvrir un
moyen terme madame la ministre madame la
ministre
mais ce président monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs 15
millions d'euros c'est précisément
l'augmentation que nous avons prévu pour
l'année 2023 pour les investissements
immobiliers à l'étranger nous avons par
ailleurs de longue date un plan
ambassade de verte qui a été lancé en
amont de la COP 21 avec de bons
résultats et nous sommes cette année
participant à l'effort gouvernementale
de sobriété énergétique ces trois
éléments conduisent le gouvernement
avoir une un avis défavorable sur ces
deux amendements
[Musique]
qui est contre
rejeté à nouveau deux amendements
identiques le 1149 monsieur Leleu
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues dans cette émission le 30 juin
2020 nous avons adopté à l'unanimité une
proposition de loi visant à créer un
fond d'urgence pour les Français de
l'étranger victimes de catastrophes
naturelles un tsunami un tremblement de
terre
d'un événement politique majeur on pense
évidemment par exemple à ce qui advient
en ce moment au Burkina Faso où on a
incendié l'Institut français bien
entendu à la guerre en Ukraine et
un événement une catastrophe sanitaire
et bien ce fond d'urgence vise justement
à créer un quatrième programme au sein
de la mission action extérieure de
l'État afin de faire face à ces
situations qui mettent en danger nos
compatriotes qui vivent à l'étranger
donc le Sénat adopter cette proposition
de loi à l'unanimité et il s'agit ici
donc d'un amendement qui crée ce fond
d'urgence alors pour reprendre les
travaux de la commission des finances
sur cette proposition de loi qui
considère que ce fond d'urgence je cite
renforcerai la sincérité des contes de
la mission action extérieure de l'État
et que les crédits alloués à se font
pourraient être pour partie ouvert en
loi de finances initiale c'est un moment
vise donc à créer un nouveau programme
au sein de la mission extérieure de
l'État comme je venais de vous le dire
je vous remercie si Madame Queneau et
Morez le même amendement en 1227
rapidement merci monsieur le Président
c'est vrai que nous avons voté
différents textes dans le temps en
faveur de l'institution d'un fond
d'urgence pour les Français de
l'étranger et puis il y a eu cette
proposition de loi qui a été votée en
2020 je crois que nous accorderons pour
dire que les catastrophes naturelles
sanitaires et politiques se sont
multipliés dans le monde des chlore
gravités et croissantes donc la création
de ce programme budgétaire doté de 10
millions d'euros vis non seulement à
traduire la volonté du Sénat mais
surtout à donner les moyens nécessaires
au service de l'État pour venir en aide
à nos compatriotes confrontés à de
telles situations
merci David la commission
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement en juin 2020 dans le
contexte de la crise sanitaire le Sénat
avait adopté une proposition de loi
déposée par le président Retailleau pour
permettre la création d'un fonds
d'urgence pour les Français de
l'étranger
l'analyse qui avait pressé au vote du
Sénat pourrait être ainsi évoluer parce
que à l'époque il y avait une diversité
de crise notamment de covid et la
diversité des crises qui sont intervenus
depuis à contribuer à faire évoluer très
fortement les modalités d'action du
ministère des Affaires étrangères avec
un renforcement sensible de ses moyens
et instruments d'intervention en
situation de crise
en tout état de cause la création d'un
programme budgétaire au sein de la
mission action extérieure de l'État ne
répond pas à la demande des auteurs de
l'approvision de loi ni au sens du vote
du Sénat l'objectif étant effet de
constituer un fond présentant des
garanties d'autonomie et dont les
crédits auraient été détaché de ceux de
la mission action extérieure de l'État
ici par définition les crédits demandés
seront rattachés à la mission action
extérieure de l'État et pilotée par le
ministère des Affaires étrangères nous
comprenons bien qu'il s'agit d'un
amendement d'appel et nous invitons donc
à le retirer à défaut notre avis serait
défavorable
du gouvernement madame la ministre
même avis monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs les cris sont
par définition imprévisible nous avons
pu chaque fois que c'était nécessaire
trouver les moyens d'abonder les crédits
lorsque c'était nécessaire et donc il ne
paraît pas
indispensable cette année de créer un
nouveau fond alors que les moyens mis à
disposition des Français de l'étranger
augmenteraient au PLF 23 avec une hausse
du budget des affaires sociales de 1
million et une hausse de plus de 10
millions au titre de LED à la scolarité
et avec la réserve de crise du CDCS en
complément
merci je mets je vois ces deux
amendements identiques avec deux avis
défavorables qui pour
qui est contre
le 1236 Monsieur themael Merci monsieur
prise dans un amendement de solidarité
avec le crâne il y a que le peuple
ukrainien puisqu'il s'agit de d'abonder
les crédits de la facilité européenne
pour la paix qui sont je le rappelle en
baisse de 6% dans le projet de budget
donc voilà donc notre idée c'est encore
une fois que la France soit la hauteur
de ces des efforts qui lui sont demandés
merci avis de la commission
monsieur le Président la facilité
européenne pour la paix est un
instrument de l'Union européenne
financée par les États membres qui
permet de financement d'action relevant
de la politique étrangère de sécurité
commune ce mécanisme finance ainsi des
opérations d'aide au maintien de la paix
en Afrique mais également depuis cette
année en Ukraine
au début de la discussion budgétaire les
crédits demandés pour financer la
cote-part de la France à cette facilité
s'élevée à 67,8 millions en baisse d'un
peu moins de 10 millions par rapport à
ce montant est appelé à évoluer puisque
au moment du dépôt du PLF le montant
précis de la cote par française n'était
pas connue à cet égard nous demanderons
la vie du gouvernement sur cet
amendement afin qu'il ne fournissent les
estimations les plus récentes du montant
de la quote-part française
ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je voudrais rappeler d'abord
que dans le cadre de la facilité
européenne de paix mon ministère
contribue uniquement à la part non
létale permise par la FEP les mesures
d'assistance relevant du domaine
militaire sont prises en charge en très
grande majorité sur le budget évidemment
du mystère des armées mais je veux
rassurer le sénateur temal des
discussions sont en cours entre États
membres afin d'abonder si nécessaire la
facilité européenne de paix en vue de la
fin de cette année ou du début de
l'année prochaine
merci donc avis défavorable j'imagine la
ministre
moi je m'en fiche à 18h je suspends
on fait des efforts on fait des efforts
mais vous voyez il y a quand même des
amendements qui sont importants parce
que nous parlons de budget mais il y a
des paroles qui balayent des milliards
il y a des paroles qui balayent
l'engagement de dizaines d'agents du
Quai d'Orsay de centaines de Français
qui se mobilisent pour l'Ukraine lorsque
le président de la République parle à un
moment où la Russie bombarde l'Ukraine
de donner des garanties de donner des
garanties de sécurité à la Russie madame
la ministre quel que soit les efforts
quel que soit la mobilisation d'argent
qui sera fait pour l'Ukraine avec ce
type de parole nous serons en fond de
panier en fond de panier de les
solidarités vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine et
nous n'arriverons jamais à nous mettre à
niveau nécessaire de ce qu'attendre nos
partenaires pour marquer la solidarité
avec l'Ukraine
très bien allez je mets au vois le 1236
avec deux avis défavorables qui pour
qui contre
1228 madame Condom et Mouret
actuellement en 7 millions d'euros sont
prévus pour compenser la moitié du
surcoulier à la mise en place de la
réforme satutaire des personnels
détachées dans notre réseau scolaire la
même idée que l'autre moitié serait
financé par un reliquat de crédit à
louer aux bourses scolaires mais ces
crédits seront intégralement consommés
avant la fin de l'année et vous venez
d'indiquer d'ailleurs que cette soulte
serait certainement utilisée pour
absorber et surtout dû à l'inflation
c'est donc bien l'agence qui devra
supporter ce reste à charge en 2023 en
plus il est probable revalorisation
salariale pour tenir compte de
l'inflation et des taux de change
défavorables les établissements
pourraient être contraints d'augmenter
encore les frais de scolarité l'année
prochaine c'est amendement propose donc
de doubler ses crédits afin de couvrir
l'intégralité du surcoût à la charge de
l'agence cette prise en charge totale
lui offrirait je crois un vrai bol d'air
cela permettrait par exemple de
conserver la trésorerie pour financer
des projets immobiliers en absence de
capacité d'emprunt ou bien de ne pas
alourdir ces charges notamment liées à
la contribution patronale retraite prend
en charge seul depuis 2010 avril la
Commission sur rapporteur
merci Monsieur président cet amendement
donc augmente de 7 millions d'euros le
montant de la subvention versée à la FFE
pour que les chats l'étape prennent en
charge l'intégralité du coût de la
réforme du statut des personnes
résidents puisque la EFE pouvait jusqu'à
la réforme récente recrute un agent de
l'éducation nationale en position de
résident et non de personnels expatriés
mais une décision de la justice
administrative on a décidé autrement et
pour un coup pour l'agence d'environ 14
millions d'euros en 2023
il semble qu'il ait été décidé en
concertation entre la EFE et le
ministère de partager ce coup de 14
millions et nous ne proposons pas de
revenir sur cette sur ce partage puisque
c'est 7 millions d'euros peuvent être
compris dans l'augmentation de
subventions à la EFE même si je mesure
bien en disant cela également que l'on
donne beaucoup de
d'objectifs différents et
complémentaires à cette augmentation de
subventions à l'EFE pour cette année où
il y aura sûrement une inflation
importante mais la vie de la Commission
à ce stade et des favorable avait du
gouvernement de la ministre même avis
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs merci 1228 deux
avis défavorables qui pour
quiconque
quatre amendements en discussion commune
le 1234 madame Queneau et Mouret
dans tous les pays du monde nos
compatriotes subissent la crise
économique de façon plus ou moins forte
et constate la baisse de leur pouvoir
d'achat cette crise n'est pas mieux
personne ne fait que malheureusement les
plus vulnérables les élus des Français
étranger se sont d'ailleurs mobilisés
dans les conseils consulaires pour
demander des augmentations à hauteur du
niveau de vie dans leur pays de
résidence ils ont demandé par exemple de
passer de 310 à 450 euros par mois au
Cambodge et de 357 à 557 euros en
Argentine d'autres comme à Londres ont
voté à l'unanimité d'émotions en conseil
consulaire demandant la revalorisation
urgente des taux de base nous pouvons
alors déjà anticiper que malgré
l'augmentation des crédits prévus en
2023 l'ensemble des besoins ne pourront
être satisfaits les estimations de tous
les acteurs sociaux et des associations
d'entraide locale nous démontre
malheureusement que cette enveloppe est
trop limitée alors que la situation est
critique dans certaines familles nous ne
pourrons pas procéder à des ajustements
à la baisse alors où irons-nous chercher
les crédits s'ils n'ont pas été fléchés
avec ces amendements nous sommes dans
l'anticipation la réaction afin de
répondre au mieux à la fois la crise
économique qui nous frappe et à la
paupérisation de nos compatriotes à
l'étranger c'est le 1280 madame Vogel
merci monsieur le Président en effet le
pouvoir d'achat baisse l'inflation est
galopante et des situations de détresse
se multiplient pour les Françaises et
les Français de l'étranger face à cela
notre réponse doit toujours être la
protection et la justice sociale c'est
donc au nom des Françaises et des
Français de l'étranger les plus
précarisés à cause de tous ces
événements que je m'adresse à vous
aujourd'hui en vous proposant l'adoption
d'un véritable plan de protection des
Françaises et des Français de l'étranger
de 5 millions d'euros à quoi servirait
ces 5 millions d'euros un compenser les
variations de taux de change des aides
sociales attribuées par des conseils
consulaires pour la protection et
l'action sociale les ccpas à compenser
des effets de l'inflation à mettre en
place un véritable mécanisme de
transition pour ceux qui étaient
allocataires de SOS covid jusqu'à l'été
2022 et qui n'ont pas pu retrouver des
situations financières stables à
permettre un abaissement du taux
d'incapacité à 50% au lieu de 80%, pour
être éligible aux aides dispensés par
des CCAS
à l'instar de la location adulte
handicapée sur le territoire national
ces mesures semblent être un minimum
pour s'assurer qu'aucun français ou
qu'aucune française de l'étranger ne
soit abandonnée à son sort en ces temps
difficiles je vous remercie
le 1238 monsieur Lecomte il a été
excellent par mes collègues mais
monsieur le Président aimerait voir de
votre côté un peu d'enthousiasme dans ce
débat aussi
vous verrez l'enthousiasme à 18h si je
dis que c'est terminé
parce que c'est vous qui aurait moins
d'enthousiasme si je vous dis que vous
êtes reporté à 1h du matin
le 1142 madame renaud-garde merci
monsieur le Président pour revenir à ce
que mes collègues viennent d'exposer où
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec eux je
voulais rajouter quelque chose c'est
qu'entre 2021 et 2022 les crédits
sociales ont baissé d'un million d'euros
et l'augmentation qui est prévue cette
année ne fait que de équilibrer ce
million d'euros qui est absorbé en
totalité par l'inflation que nous
constatons en 2022 et encore qui ne
tient pas compte de celle de 2023
merci
Eric la commission
merci monsieur le Président donc la vie
de la commission des finances sur ces
quatre amendements même s'ils ont un
montant différent et défavorable donc
désolé de doucher les enthousiasmes
c'est vrai que
nous sommes dans une année de sortie du
dispositif SOS covid ce qui peut donner
un sentiment de baisse décrédible mais
hors dispositif SOS covid les crédits
s'élèvent à 16,2 millions d'euros dans
le projet de budget soit une
augmentation d'environ 1,2 millions
d'euros et de 8% c'est nettement enfin
c'est légèrement supérieur à l'inflation
qui est prévue nous estimons donc que de
tels crédits doivent être augmentés en
cours d'année si la situation sociale le
justifie et non pas a priori donc avis
défavorable sur ces quatre amendements
si la vie du gouvernement madame la
ministre
même avis monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs
alors le 1234 2 avis défavorables qui
pour
qui contre
1282 avis défavorable qui pour
le 1238 de David défavorable qui pour
qui contre rejeté le 1142 de avis
défavorable Kippour
nous passons 1279 de Madame Vogel
merci monsieur le Président le
gouvernement a décidé depuis 2021 de
créer une nouvelle branche autonomie de
la sécurité sociale pour mieux protéger
les politiques publiques de l'autonomie
alors que fuser les scandales et que nos
aînés payés le prix fort pendant la
crise covid j'aimerais vous proposer
l'équivalent pour les Françaises et les
Français de l'étranger et c'est pourquoi
cet amendement propose la création d'un
nouveau programme dédié à
l'accompagnement et à la prise en charge
de la perte d'autonomie des Françaises
et des Français de l'étranger d'un coup
de 5 millions d'euros pourquoi
sinon nombreux Françaises et Français de
l'étranger sont affiliés à la CFE à la
Caisse des Français de l'étranger
beaucoup sont encore attachés la
sécurité sociale leurs besoins de santé
peuvent ainsi être couverts mais pas
leur perte d'autonomie pour vous ça ne
doit peut-être pas sembler grave mais
imaginez un vieil homme qui a travaillé
la moitié de sa carrière à l'étranger
pas forcément bien rémunéré et qui
souhaitent couler des jours heureux pour
sa retraite hors de France
mais qui commence à avoir je sais pas la
maladie de Parkinson cet homme aurait
besoin d'être sur place pas d'être
rapatriés en France dans un EHPAD les
consulats devraient être formés sur ces
problématiques et pouvoir aiguiller nos
citoyens et citoyens expatriés et aucune
personne perdant son autonomie de
devrait être laissée sur le carreau je
vous remercie merci à vous de la
Commission
oui monsieur le Président
chers collègues nous sommes défavorables
à cet amendement qui anticipe les leçons
qui seront tirées de la mise en oeuvre
de la branche autonomie de la sécurité
sociale la réforme de la prise en charge
des Français de l'étranger doit sur ce
point faire l'objet d'une réflexion plus
approfondie qu'un amendement de 5
millions d'euros comme cela en
discussion budgétaire donc c'est un avis
défavorable avis du gouvernement madame
ministre
ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs mais ma vie de la part du
gouvernement
je mets au voile 1279 avec deux avis
défavorables qui pour
qui contre
1240 monsieur Lecomte si monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nous proposons par cet
amendement la création d'un nouveau
programme assemblée des Français de
l'étranger dotés des moyens qui sont
actuellement inscrits dans le programme
151 parce qu'il n'est pas normal que les
moyens qui sont dévolus au
fonctionnement de l'Assemblée des
Français d'étrangers au conseiller des
Français de l'étranger mais aussi les
subventions staff dépendent du programme
151 nous constatons progressivement un
étiollement de la manière dont ça
fonctionne nous constatons qu'il n'y a
plus de personnel dédiés exclusivement
au fonctionnement de l'Assemblée des
Français d'étrangers ils sont juste dans
l'organigramme de la DFE nous constatons
que le staff qui initialement a remplacé
la réserve parlementaire pour servir
l'ensemble des activités associatives
des Français vivant à l'étranger
aujourd'hui en est réduit à répondre aux
besoins et aux moyens et aux objectifs
de du programme 151 et pas plus c'est la
raison pour laquelle pour dire stop pour
donner un budget à l'Assemblée des
Français d'étrangers et élargir le son
du staff nous proposons la création d'un
programme spécifique auquel j'espère
l'ensemble de l'Assemblée
autour duquel j'espère l'assemblée se
retrouvera avis de la commission sur la
porte
merci monsieur le Président
au-delà du fond il y a deux raisons qui
nous conduisent au nom de la Commission
à donner un avis défavorable à
l'amendement présenté par Jean-Yves
Leconte d'une part la création de ce
nouveau programme ne répond pas
entièrement à votre souhait c'est à dire
que les crédits de ce nouveau programme
créé resterait quand même à la main du
ministère des Affaires étrangères qui
pourraient les mobiliser pour d'autres
programmes donc aujourd'hui dans
l'organisation j'imagine des services du
ministère et de la DFAE sa créerait une
rigidité mais si cette rigidité dans
l'affectation des personnels étaient
souhaitées elles ne de toute façon elle
ne serait pas entièrement
rendu possible par cette par cette
amendement lui-même ensuite la création
d'un programme dans le cadre de
l'article 7 de la LOLF prévoit que les
programmes concourent à des politiques
publiques définies est-ce que on serait
là dans le cadre de la création d'une
politique publique en tant que telle je
n'en suis pas certain et donc en réalité
l'objectif poursuivi par l'amendement
qui peut paraître tout à fait légitime
je nous ne pensons pas qu'ils peuvent se
concrétiser par un amendement à la loi
de à la loi de finances elle-même voilà
pourquoi nous donnons un avis
défavorable le gouvernement madame la
ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs le Gouvernement
est défavorable à cette proposition
puisque la modification de la
nomenclature des programmes ne peut
permettre budgétaire constant que
demeurer sans incidence sur les actions
déjà conduites au profit de l'AFE mais
compliquerait beaucoup la gestion en
effet la rigidifiant
donc bien d'accord alors je mets au
voile 1240 avec deux avis défavorables
qui pour
qui est contre
1243 monsieur chanterelle oui monsieur
le Président c'est amendement il vise à
créer un pass Culture pour les jeunes
Français de l'étranger contrairement au
collégien et lycéens de France les
jeunes Français établir de France n'ont
pas accès au Pass Culture ce dispositif
qui depuis 2017 favorise l'accès à la
culture afin de renforcer et diversifier
les pratiques culturelles des jeunes
tout en révélant la richesse culturelle
des territoires or il est essentiel
d'entretenir chez les jeunes Français de
15 à 18 ans établis hors de France des
liens forts avec la culture française et
francophone à laquelle ils sont par
définition moins exposées qu'à la
culture du pays d'accueil le dispositif
du Pass Culture pour les zen Français de
l'étranger doit être ciblé vers des
acteurs culturels Français établis hors
de France qui sont qui en serait donc
les partenaires les Alliances françaises
les instituts français bien sûr mais
aussi les librairies françaises galeries
françaises ou cinéma français la
création ne se passe culture pour jeune
Français étrangers vise donc un double
objectif encourager les pratiques
culturelles en autonomie des jeunes
Français établis hors de France et
promouvoir aussi l'ensemble de nos
acteurs culturels français établis en
France qui favorise le rayonnement de
notre langue et notre patrimoine
culturel hors de France
avis de la commission
et monsieur le Président ne comprenons
parfaitement l'objectif de cette
amendement qui est sur le fond peut-être
partagé il faut savoir que effectivement
le Pass sanitaire de passe culture
pardon
lapsus révélateur le Pass Culture et
d'un montant d'environ 300 euros et
concerne les jeunes de 15 à 18 ans il y
en a quand même 100000 à l'étranger donc
si on fait le rapport 300 euros par
100000 ça nous fait 30 millions d'euros
donc c'est dix fois le montant de cette
amendement
il nous semble qu'il faudrait quand même
préciser un petit peu les besoins
et regarder si effectivement
c'est 30 millions d'euros devraient
venir du ministère des Affaires
étrangères ou plutôt du ministère de la
Culture donc il y a encore beaucoup de
questions que l'on se pose c'est pour
cela que on émet un avis défavorable à
ce moment-là avis du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
gouvernement aimait également un avis
défavorable tout en rappelant que pour
les jeunes Français à l'étranger notre
réseau culturel les ambassades les
instituts les Alliances françaises et
d'autres offrent déjà une gamme de
services sans doute sans équivalent dans
le monde interdire de spectacle vivant
comme dans d'autres matières avec les
très nombreuses médiathèques et
bibliothèques que nous aidons
très bien je mets aux vois le 1243 avec
deux avis défavorables qui pour
qui est contre
rejeter le 1241 monsieur 73
oui monsieur le Président la
multiplication des crises
internationales entre l'épidémie de
covid et la crise de l'énergie liée à
l'invasion de l'Ukraine a conduit de
nombreuses familles à travers le monde à
repenser leur priorités cela n'a pas été
sans conséquence sur la mobilité
internationale des étudiantes et
étudiants à ce titre l'attractivité
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
français est mis à mal or il subissent
déjà une baisse d'attractivité depuis
2019 avec le décuplement des frais
universitaires pour les étudiants
extra-communautaires face à ces
difficultés Campus France a plus que
jamais besoin de moyens supplémentaires
pour attirer davantage et mieux
accueillir les étudiants étrangers dans
les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur français c'est l'objectif de
ces amendements en abandon en abondant
justement le programme de Campus France
de 3 millions d'euros
merci avis de la commission
merci monsieur le Président il faut
accueillir davantage d'étudiants
étrangers mais vous comprendrez qu'il
faut d'abord le faire en consommant les
crédits de la mission qui est crédits
non consommé à ce stade de l'année je
pense que Madame la miss pourrait le
confirmer mais surtout les années
précédentes sont importants et d'un
montant plus élevé que 3 millions
d'euros donc avis défavorable dans la
mesure où avant d'ajouter 3 millions
d'euros à la mission il faudrait d'abord
consommer les crédits de la mission
elle-même avait du gouvernement
même avis monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs sous
consommation en effet merci je mets aux
voix le 1241 avec deux avis défavorables
qui pour
qui compte
discussion commune le 1219 monsieur
Leleu
merci monsieur le Président CCI France
International regroupe et anime 125
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
française à l'international dans 95 pays
elle est garante de l'appellation
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
française de l'international et a pour
mission de rassembler représenté
coordonnées et développer le réseau des
CCI françaises à l'international il
s'agit aujourd'hui de renforcer l'action
et les moyens pour en faire le véritable
bras armé de notre pays à
l'international en effet dans un
contexte économique tendu la France se
doit de conserver un réseau fort à
l'étranger pour accompagner nos
entreprises pour favoriser la
coopération et le transfert de
savoir-faire entre elles pour poursuivre
son travail de structuration et de
consolidation des communautés d'affaires
à l'étranger pour développer la
formation de ses collaborateurs pour ce
faire c'est amendement propose un fond
de soutien pour le développement du
réseau des Chambres de Commerce et
d'Industrie française à l'international
ce fond a pour objectif de permettre aux
directeur de chambre de commerce et
d'industrie française à l'international
de bénéficier de formation conforme aux
objectifs de la team France Export et
visant
à renforcer la convergence des méthodes
du réseau de recruter des volontaires
internationaux en administration pour
renforcer les coordinations régionales
de renforcer la digitalisation du réseau
des CCI François internationales et de
favoriser la mise en relation des
communautés d'affaires merci le 1255
madame Colombes
chacun de mes déplacements
les représentants du champ de commerce
et d'industrie française à l'étranger
sont des acteurs économiques qui sont de
véritables soutiens à notre commerce
extérieur qui en a bien besoin ils font
partie je crois de nos meilleurs relais
au sein de notre équipe France à
l'étranger alors c'est vrai que nous
avons un réseau qui pourrait être
aujourd'hui soutenu et qui est vraiment
sous pression
d'un comment d'une concurrence très très
forte venant souvent d'ailleurs de pays
amis localement ce sont des chambres de
commerce qui sont souvent très anciennes
qui sont bien implantés et qui
aujourd'hui est bien aide nos
entreprises françaises sur les marchés
internationaux mettant à disposition des
locaux
ainsi que un soutien logistique et
administratif et puis c'est sans compter
des missions de formation et d'aide à
l'emploi auprès des Français de
l'étranger et des collaborateurs locaux
et donc dans ce contexte de plus en plus
concurrentiel certains nos partenaires
sont également donc nos adversaires
économiques les plus sérieux c'est un
moment visa renforcer notre réseau afin
de lui donner les moyens de se
développer
merci avis de la commission
oui monsieur le Président ces deux
amendements identiques visent à créer un
programme doté de 2,5 millions d'euros
pour le développement des chambres de
commerce international nous sommes
défavorables à cet amendement pour deux
raisons d'abord car la création d'un tel
programme ne serait pas conforme au
disposition de l'article 7 de la LOLF
qui prévoit que les programmes de
démission correspondent à des politiques
publiques définies la création d'un
fonds de soutien n'est pas en elle-même
une politique publique et la deuxième
raison c'est que ces compétences ne
relèvent plus de la mission action
extérieure de l'État dans la compétence
économique via business France que la
compétence a tourisme via la souffrance
relève de la mission du même nom la
mission économie donc il n'y a aucune
raison que les crédits de la diplomatie
soient mis à contribution pour financer
ce qui relève de la politique économique
et d'exportation de la France donc avis
défavorable s'il y avait du gouvernement
mais ma vie monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
merci je me vouvoie le 1219 et le 1255
sont pas tout à fait identiques avec
deux avis défavorables qui pour
qui contre
allez
le 1231 madame que non et
oui
2,5 millions d'euros à notre poste
diplomatique à Ouagadou Ouaga
pour reconstruire et sécuriser ses
locaux estimations éminents
je recommence estimation émanant c'est
mieux dans les directions des immeubles
et de la logistique du ministère lorsque
notre ambassade et notre institut au
Burkina Faso ont été dégradées si
l'image de la France mais surtout le
lieu de travail de nos personnels qui
ont été attaqués ces crédits
permettraient donc de le rassurer des
conditions de travail sereine et surtout
en toute sécurité
merci
commission oui monsieur le Président
nous sommes défavorables aussi à cet
amendement car la hausse des crédits
demandés n'est pas nécessaire le coût de
ces travaux ont été pris en compte dans
l'enveloppe des crédits demandés pour
l'entretien lourd à l'étranger en 2023
donc c'est satisfait donc on aura des
vies défavorable merci merci
le Président mes amis et messieurs les
sénateurs parfait 1231 deux avis
négatifs qui est pour
qui est contre rejeté deux amendements
de discussion commune le 1239 monsieur
Lecomte merci monsieur le Président
Madame ministre mes chers collègues
c'est un abonnement important nous avons
besoin de doter d'un million et demi en
plus le programme 151 pour faciliter
l'accès à la Caisse des Français à
l'étranger les crédits d'aide social
sont trop faibles pour envisager que ce
soit pris sur eux pourtant la Caisse des
Français à l'étranger coûte cher depuis
2019 le gouvernement a exclu du du droit
à la carte Vitale les retraités qui
n'avaient pas cotisé 15 ans en France
c'est la raison pour laquelle énormément
de Français qui vivent à l'étranger et
en particulier de retraités non plus la
capacité aujourd'hui d'avoir une
assurance maladie lorsqu'il rentre en
France
l'accès à la Caisse des Français à
l'étranger est trop cher pour un certain
nombre de personnes aux revenus trop bas
la Caisse des Français d'étrangers a
créé il y a maintenant à peu près 20 ans
la catégorie aider l'État s'était engagé
à financer la moitié de l'effort que la
Caisse des Français à l'étrangerait
depuis quelques années ça n'est plus le
cas nous avons besoin madame la ministre
d'un engagement précis de l'état pour
que l'État continue à accompagner les
efforts que fait la CFE pour s'ouvrir et
financer la catégorie des c'est l'objet
de cet amendement
1277 madame Vogel merci monsieur
président cet amendement va dans le même
sens donc comme mon collègue Jean-Yves
Le compte l'a dit il existe une
catégorie aider à la Caisse des Français
de l'étranger qui permet que l'État
prenne en charge une partie des
cotisations pour aider les personnes les
plus précaires mais il y a plusieurs
problèmes premièrement en général l'état
subventionne très très peu la CFE depuis
des années ce qui l'empêche en retour de
pouvoir aider les expatriés précaires le
budget du PLF propose 380 000 euros de
financement de l'État pour la CFE en
2023 380
000 euros c'est ridicule dois-je vous
rappeler qu'il était de 2,6 millions
d'euros il y a 15 ans 380000 euros c'est
le prix de je sais pas un appartement de
70 mètres carrés à Marseille voilà et ça
c'est la sécurité sociale pour les plus
précaires les Français de l'étranger
c'est un montant ridicule en soi est
encore plus au regard des coûts généraux
de la CFE au regard de l'inflation qui
augmente et au regard de la
précarisation accrue du public duquel on
l'année passée
2156 personnes ont bénéficié de la
catégorie aidé de la CFE celle qui est
portée par l'État et plus de personnes
en auront très peu très probablement
besoin en 2023 ça veut dire en gros que
cette aide coûte 1855 euros par personne
et sur ces 1855 euros l'état porte 176
euros voilà donc cet amendement propose
d'augmenter le financement par l'état de
la CFE pour faire face à la hausse de la
catégorie idée de la CFE pour que l'État
prenne en charge un peu plus par
personne aider pour que ces montants
soient adaptés à l'inflation et tout
simplement pour que l'État tienne ces
engagements je vous remercie avis de la
commission
monsieur le Président effectivement la
Caisse des Français de l'étranger était
une caisse de sécurité sociale
c'est-à-dire un organisme privé assurant
une mission de service public
depuis 2002 la CFE met en oeuvre un
dispositif de prise en charge en faveur
des Français résidents de l'espace
européen dont les revenus sont
inférieurs à 50 % du plafond de la
sécurité sociale
ce test positif fait l'objet d'un
abonnement ça a été dit de la part de
l'état de 380000 euros les auteurs les
amendements proposent de multiplier ce
cet abonnement par 5 ce qui nous paraît
excessif donc nous sommes défavorables à
cet amendement
avec deux avis défavorables qui pour
qui est contre
le 1277 deux avis des favorables qui
pour
qui est contre rejeté
le 1226 madame
Louis aux organismes locaux d'entraide
et de solidarité en 2023 91 associations
locales bénéficieront d'une dotation de
1,4 millions d'euros identique à celle
de 2022 celle-ci n'est pas suffisante
pour deux raisons et nous le savons déjà
d'une part l'expérience l'a montré
puisque 2,17 millions ont été consommés
en 2020 et 1,7 millions en 2021 d'autre
part il est à prévoir que l'extinction
du dispositif du secours occasionnel de
solidarité versée par les Conseils
consulaires pour la protection et
l'action sociale pendant la pandémie
entraînera le report des demandeurs
d'aide sociale vers les olesses enfin il
faut anticiper l'inflation et la baisse
du cours de l'euro sur lequel repose les
aides sociales je crois que je viens de
faire la démonstration que ces crédits
sont insuffisants nous proposons donc de
doubler de les doubler pour avoir une
enveloppe qui répondent aux besoins
réels des familles et non une enveloppe
à minima dans laquelle nous essayons de
les faire rentrer nous avons soutenu nos
compatriotes pendant la crise sanitaire
nous ne pouvons pas les abandonner face
à la crise économique mondiale qui en
résulte
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues je vis de la commission est le
même sur cet amendement de même connu et
Mouret que sur les autres amendements
relatifs à l'aide sociale c'est un avis
négatif défavorable à ce stade et par
exemple au premier décembre 2022 1,2
millions je crois d'euros des crédits
sur les 1,4 ont été consommés donc les
crédits apparaissent suffisants
néanmoins je pense que sur ces crédits
d'aide sociale qu'il relève des aullais
sous noms cette à la situation sociale
réelle dans le monde dans le courant de
l'année 2023 d'être prise en compte dans
l'éventuelle projet de loi de finance
rectificatif qui interviendra en cours
d'année pour pouvoir s'adapter à la
réalité des besoins dans le cours de
l'année
avis du gouvernement dans le ministre
mais ma fille monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs en
effet les crédits ont été suffisants en
2022 et je voudrais rappeler que le
nombre de demandes de subventions à
diminuer lors de la campagne 2022 il y a
eu 103 demandes contre 149 l'année
précédente
merci le 1226 avec deux avis
défavorables qui pour
quiconque
madame Colomiers ah Monsieur Chantrel
oui monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement vise à soutenir à hauteur
d'un million d'euros supplémentaire nos
alliances françaises qui sont très
impactées encore aujourd'hui par la
crise sanitaire à laquelle vient
s'ajouter la crise économique et
énergétique nos alliances françaises
comme vous le savez sont des
associations de droit local privé à 90%
autofinancé par des cours de français
qui bénéficient de subventions publiques
pour l'organisation d'événements
culturels après les confinements
successifs leurs ressources propres ont
été affaiblies jusqu'à menacées pour
certaines d'entre elles leur survie de
plus aujourd'hui elle se retrouve en
concurrence avec des organismes
d'enseignement en ligne qui sont nés se
sont multipliés pendant les confinements
donc avant de penser éventuellement au
développement de nouvelles alliances ne
devrions-nous pas justement nous assurer
d'aider celles qui existent déjà et
tente de survivre et de les consolider
celles qui traversent des difficultés
c'est pourquoi nous proposons justement
de fléchir un million d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires
merci avis de la commission
merci monsieur le Président donc
l'amendement que vient de présenter Yann
chanterelle propose d'augmenter de 1
million d'euros les crédits ouverts en
faveur des Alliances françaises mais il
nous apparaît que les crédits en 2022 du
même montant sont pour le moment
loin d'être consommé entièrement
3,9 millions d'euros consommés 4,5
millions d'euros engagés au 1er décembre
2022 et donc il nous semble pas que
aujourd'hui il y a besoin d'augmenter
d'un million d'euros les crédits des
Alliances françaises mais plutôt de
consommer l'ensemble des crédits
budgétés
même avis monsieur le Président merci le
1229 de avis des favorables qui pour
qui contre rejeté
1230 madame Conway
l'Institut français est stable avec 28
millions d'euros si l'Institut français
n'a pas de responsabilité de l'animation
du réseau culturel français à l'étranger
il apporte son concours 94 instituts
répartis dans le monde pour
l'organisation des événements culturels
à l'étranger alors ces derniers ont été
fortement impactés par les crises
sanitaires et économiques les
confinements ont eux aussi en
conséquence la baisse de leur activité
d'enseignement et donc on pesait sur les
ressources propres à cela s'ajoute des
factures énergétiques en hausse qui
risque d'aggraver les trésories déjà
fortement impacté le soutien apporté par
l'Institut à Paris ne pourra que
renforcer les activités culturelles et
l'image des instituts locaux et attirer
à nouveau des publics dont il en grand
besoin de plus depuis la sortie de la
pandémie l'augmentation de la demande
sur le secteur culturel et artistique
est exponentiel les artistes français
ont été empêchés de travailler pendant
selon moi et pour beaucoup aller à
l'étranger fait partie de leur mission
c'est subvention exceptionnelle
permettrait à la fois d'assurer un
soutien la visibilité à l'international
de nos artistes français et soutenir
aussi l'activité culturelle locale en
mettant en lumière le travail des
artistes locaux notre scène française
participe à la promotion à
l'international de nos valeurs telles
que la liberté d'expression et du
circulation dont nous avons je crois
grande besoins grandement besoin
aujourd'hui
avis de la commission
merci monsieur le Président donc
l'amendement propose d'augmenter la
subvention de l'Institut français et des
instituts français dans leur ensemble
autant ils ne nous paraît pas nécessaire
d'augmenter la subvention de l'Institut
français par rapport au budget qui nous
est présenté la stratégie étant plutôt
de l'inciter à développer ses ressources
propres autant sur la dotation de
fonctionnement aux instituts français
dans le monde nous avons vu que ceci
malgré des recettes qui progressent de
manière dynamique ont aussi des déficits
qui doivent nous appeler à la vigilance
et son confrontés à l'inflation ainsi
qu'à des charges de personnel en hausse
donc nous sommes intéressés de connaître
la vie du gouvernement quand on risque
financier auxquels sont exposés ces
instituts et sur l'opportunité
d'augmenter d'un million d'euros les
crédits qui leur sont dédiés ah oui du
gouvernement madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les Center la vie
du Gouvernement est favorable il y en
avait fait un point de vigilance sur la
trésorerie des instituts français qui a
souffert un peu partout dans le monde de
deux années de pandémie qui ont réduit
bien souvent les activités de ces
instituts et non pas permis qu'ils
engrangent les recettes qu'ils ont
Grangé habituellement nous sommes
repartis à la hausse et avec un recours
plus systématique au numérique donc sur
une meilleure tendance désormais mais je
prends bien note du point de vigilance
donc à vivre défavorable et favorable ou
favorable défavorable défavorable et
vigilance en effet sur la suite
donc avis de la commission défavorable
je mets au vois le 1230 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
1235 madame Conway Mouret
la France se bénéficie d'un vivier
important de volontaire internationaux
en même temps là donc la France
bénéficie d'un vivier important de
volontaire internationaux en
administration aussi appelé via qui
effectue un service civique auprès des
services de l'État français à l'étranger
les consulats ambassade service mission
économique Service de Coopération et
d'Action culturelles c'est souvent une
très belle opportunité pour ces jeunes
de 18 ans à 28 ans qui bénéficiait alors
d'une première et solide expérience
professionnelle à l'étranger mais avec
la crise économique leur pouvoir d'achat
notamment en Amérique du Nord est
impactée par l'inflation il est taux de
change très défavorables il lui vient
très difficile pour Sévilla de se loger
de se nourrir de se chauffer de se
déplacer certains sont forcés de
déménager dans les quartiers lointains
ou la sécurité n'est pas optimale ce qui
ajoute également des frais de
déplacement supplémentaires l'impact sur
le moral des équipes se fait ressentir
avec une paire de motivation et certains
contrats s'arrêtent prématurément ce qui
déséquilibre le travail des équipes si
l'indemnité supplémentaire des
volontaires internationaux a été
valoriser le 1er octobre en Amérique du
Nord elle semble encore insuffisante la
proposition de réévaluation du barème
des vias et des vies dans ce PLF est une
bonne mesure et devait être encore plus
soutenu c'est pourquoi je vous propose
c'est amendement
avis de la commission oui monsieur le
Président chers collègue la rémunération
d'un volontaire international en
administration et composé de deux
éléments d'un élément une part fixe et
une part variable qui elle est réévaluée
tous les trois mois
en fonction de la nature de la mission
ainsi que l'évolution du taux de change
et de l'inflation donc l'objectif des
auteurs de l'amendement nous apparaît
satisfait par le droit en vigueur donc
la vie des favorable avait du
gouvernement
avis défavorable également nous avons
revalorisé cette année d'un million six
pour tenir compte précisément de la
hausse de l'inflation et souvent du coût
du logement
merci je mets au voile 1235 avec deux
avis négatifs qui pour
qui contre
rejeté trois amendements discussion
commune le 1217 monsieur Leleu
merci monsieur le président
les conseillères et conseiller des
Français de l'étranger les conseillères
et conseillers à l'Assemblée des
Français de l'étranger sont des élus au
suffrage universel
il ne touche pas d'indemnités ils sont
bénévoles
seulement voilà dans l'exercice de leur
mandat évidemment il y a quelques frais
de déplacement ne serait-ce que pour
participer à un conseil d'école dans un
lycée français à l'étranger
et donc une partie maudite de ces frais
de mandat est couvertes
on est dans une situation tellement
absurde aujourd'hui avec l'inflation que
pour les conseillers à l'Assemblée des
Français de l'étranger qui sont appelés
à siéger deux fois par an à Paris en
général au mois de mars pendant une
semaine et au mois d'octobre pendant une
autre semaine
les frais de déplacement et les nuits
d'hôtel n'étant pas couvertes par tout
simplement l'exercice du mandat et bien
nous avons des élus au suffrage
universel qui tout simplement se
refusent de faire le déplacement à Paris
alors qu'ils sont élus pour siéger dans
cette assemblée
donc on est face à une absurdité
démocratique
l'objet de cet amendement c'est tout
simplement de leur permettre d'exercer
le mandat pour lequel ils sont élus
démocratiquement et de leur donner les
moyens tout simplement que le billet
d'avion soit effectivement payé par la
République pour pouvoir exercer le
mandat pour lequel ils ont été élus
voici l'objet de cet amendement je vous
remercie et
identique le 1276 madame Vogel merci
monsieur le Président je voulais juste
rajouter un élément par rapport à la
défense de mon collègue Roland Leleux
que je partage totalement c'est que le
fait de rendre possible l'exercice du
mandat par des élus c'est aussi une
question de justice sociale et d'égalité
devant la capacité à concourir à des
mandats électifs si le dédommagement que
vous avez pour vos frais ne couvre pas
vos frais si quand vous devez partir
pendant une semaine deux fois dans
l'année et bien il n'y a pas
d'indemnisation satisfaisante la
conséquence ça va être que seulement
quelques personnes qui seront des
revenus très importants soit ont des
conditions socio-économiques qui le
permettent soit non plus de travail soit
non pas de famille soit non pas de
personnes qui peuvent prendre soin de
leurs enfants quand ils ou elles se
déplace qui vont pouvoir
candidater à ces élections et
représenter les Françaises et les
Français de l'étranger or nos
compatriotes à l'étranger Elise des
personnes dans leur grande diversité qui
les représentent dans leur diversité de
tout milieux sociaux professionnels de
toutes catégorie sociaux
professionnelles et c'est une question
d'égalité devant la démocratie c'est une
c'est un principe républicain que de
permettre à toute personne qui était
lutte exercer son mandat comptablement
je vous remercie c'est le 1143 madame
Renaud cabezian gardez bien merci
monsieur le Président je voudrais
rajouter un complément à ce que viennent
dire mes deux collègues il y a un
rapport récent qui a été rendu par la fe
notamment par Madame Warda Sully qui
précise que cet amendement
que ce sont les seuls élus de la
République qui se trouvent être dans
cette situation merci
avis de la commission sur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues donc les auteurs de ces
amendements évoquent des situations
où le niveau des indemnités de
déplacement serait trop fait pour
couvrir les frais véritablement engagés
par des élus bénévoles puisque c'est ce
sont des conseillers bénévoles
d'une part cette situation ne serait
concernée que les conseillers membres de
l'Assemblée des Français d'étrangers
puisque les conseillers considèrent
disposent le cas échéant d'une dotation
complémentaire qui permet de rembourser
la différence entre les frais de
déplacement engagés et un taux
forfaitaire fixé par décret d'autre part
cette situation si elle existe paraît
être relativement marginal en toute état
de cause elle ne serait justifiée à elle
seule d'augmenter de 535.000 euros les
crédits dédiés aux indemnités ce qui
correspond à une augmentation de 25% des
crédits demandés
par ailleurs les modalités
d’indemnisation des conseillers des
Français de l'étranger relève
formellement du domaine réglementaire
aussi l'amendement s'il était adopté
n'aurait pas directement pour effet
d'augmenter le montant des indemnités
donc notre avis est défavorable avis du
gouvernement ministre mais ma vie de la
part du gouvernement monsieur le
Président très bien donc avec deux avis
défavorables nous avons d'abord le 1217
et le 1276 identiques qui est pour
attendez lever clairement la main
merci quai contre
adopter
sur le 1143 tombes puisque les deux
autres ont été adoptés le 1141 madame
Renaud Garabedian en discussion commune
le président les Françaises vivant à
l'étranger qui sont victimes de
violences conjugales de bénéficie
d'aucune aide financière et sont
orientés vers les consulats vers des
structures d'accueil qui sont liées à
des associations loin des idées reçues
sur le confort des expatriés
l'éloignement peut être un déclencheur
des violences conjugales en effet
l'éloignement géographique accroît
l'isolement économique et social pas de
compte bancaire qui leur sont propres
dépendance financière éloignement des
amis de la famille et des proches pas de
connaissances de la langue et dans
certains cas ils n'ont pas le droit de
travailler elles n'ont pas de visa cet
amendement vise à créer une aide à
destination des victimes françaises de
violences conjugales à l'étranger pour
leur permettre de quitter le domicile
conjugal et repondir localement si elles
ne peuvent pas sortir du pays par
exemple du fait des enfants d'une
procédure judiciaire qui existe et de
regagner la France en finançant des
billets d'avion pour elle et également
pour leurs enfants merci le 1269 madame
Vogel
merci monsieur le Président cet
abonnement va dans le même sens il
propose d'augmenter enfin de doter dans
le fond de 500.000 euros pour les
victimes de violence conjugales à
l'étranger
la réalité c'est que les Françaises qui
vivent à l'étranger et qui sont victimes
de violences conjugales se retrouvent
dans des situations de précarité encore
plus importante que celle qui vivent en
France quand elles sont mariées à un
homme qui est national du pays qui
maîtrise le droit qui est capable de les
forcer à rester qui est capable
d'accéder à la garde des enfants quand
elles n'ont pas accès à des avocats
quand elle ne parle pas la langue du
pays ce sont des situations dramatiques
parfois des femmes se voient obligés de
rester dans le pays dans lequel elles
vivent parce que elles ont leurs enfants
qu'elles ne peuvent pas des rapatriés
avec elles alors qu'elles vivent des
violences et parfois elle manque
énormément de conseils juridiques c'est
pour ça nous considérons que ce budget
est important ça fait partie je crois
des priorités affichées du gouvernement
pour la France
hexagonale métropolitaine je crois que
les Françaises qui vivent à l'étranger
méritent la même attention merci avis de
la commission
oui monsieur le Président le sujet
soulevé par les auteurs de ses
amendements est un vrai sujet de
préoccupation
nous interrogerons sur les marges de
manœuvre concrètes dont dispose
aujourd'hui les postes consulaires pour
financer de telles opérations les
membres de la commission de des finances
ne sont pas omniscient et donc nous
demandons l'avis du Gouvernement avis du
gouvernement ministre mais ce Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
l'avis du Gouvernement sera défavorable
pour des raisons que je voudrais exposer
d'abord des aides sociales sont d'ores
et déjà attribuées sur conditions de
ressources à toute personne en
difficulté à l'étranger il s'agit
notamment de la location a duré
indéterminée qui peut être allouée à nos
ressortissants sans difficulté à la
suite d'une séparation résultant d'un
conflit familial lié au non lié à des
violences intrafamiliales et un secours
mensuel spécifique peut également être
octroyé aux enfants
deuxièmement les Françaises et Français
en situation de difficulté à l'étranger
peuvent solliciter des organismes loc
des solidarités les eaux laissent en
nous parlions et troisièmement lorsque
la situation le nécessite le pôle
rapatriement intervient par ailleurs en
lien avec le bureau de la protection des
mineurs et de la famille pour faciliter
le retour en France et la réinsertion
des personnes victimes de violence
conjugales et intrafamiliales enfin en
ce qui concerne la difficulté pour les
victimes de financer leur retour en
France le soutien de mon ministère se
traduit par la prise en charge
financière des titres de transport et
des formalités administratives de retour
pour la victime et la victime
accompagnée de ses enfants lorsque
toutes les autres solutions recherchées
ont été infructueuses
c'est donc j'imagine la vie négatif
d'accord sagesse
alors
oui
ministre j'entends ce que vous dites
mais je vous mets au défi de me trouver
une famille qui s'est trouvée en
difficulté de violences familiales qui a
réussi à obtenir un billet d'avion pour
entrer en France avec les enfants ou qui
a touché une aide quelconque pour
pouvoir avoir une aide et pour voir
souvenir aux besoins de elle et de sa
famille
bien alors sur ces deux amendements j'ai
la sagesse de la Commission avait
défavorable du gouvernement je fais donc
voter le 1141
avec donc sagesse de la Commission à vie
négative du gouvernement qui est pour
merci qui est contre
adopter il fait tomber l'autre il fait
tomber le 1269
le 1278 madame Vogel
merci
pour accompagner les Français établir de
France face à la dématérialisation des
services consulaires alors ne vous me
prenez pas je ne suis pas opposé à la
dématérialisation bien au contraire je
suis en faveur la dématérialisation
c'est une modernisation qui permet un
meilleur accès etc etc le sujet c'est
que pour les expatriés et pour les
personnes qui vivent à l'étranger c'est
très bien si certaines demandes peuvent
être faites en ligne rapidement
efficacement d'autant que ça évite de
devoir se déplacer dans des postes qui
sont parfois très éloignés de son
logement voilà mais il y a tout un tas
de personnes que cette dématérialisation
ne doit pas exclure en tant que
sénatrice des Français de l'étranger
j'écoute et j'ai chance avec de nombreux
de nombreuses personnes qui vivent à
l'étranger qui me font part de leurs
problèmes et de leur crainte et surtout
des personnes âgées qui ne maîtrisent
pas les nouvelles technologies qui ont
du mal à se connecter etc et qui parce
que elles sont éloignées des postes sont
particulièrement vulnérables si la
dématérialisation pas accompagné d'un
programme pour pour les aider donc voilà
cette proposition est simple c'est de
créer un programme accompagnement des
Français établir de France face à l'aide
d'un matérialisation pour que les
personnes qui puissent qui souhaitent se
rendre en présentiel dans les consulats
quel que soit la raison puisse trouver
une assistance je vous remercie merci à
vous de la Commission
oui monsieur président cher collègue
c'est vrai que ce sujet est important
que il y a beaucoup de dispositifs sur
le territoire national qui prennent en
compte cette nécessité d'accompagner un
certain démarches des matérialisées
toutefois nous serons défavorables à cet
amendement pour deux raisons la première
avec la création parce que là vous
demandez la création d'un programme et
pour nous la création d'un programme
c'est pas conforme à l'article 7 de la
Love qui prévoit qu'un programme porte
sur une politique publique définie et là
en l'occurrence vous ne définissez pas
une politique clairement voilà et la
seconde c'est que le ministère dispose
déjà de toute latitude pour mettre en
oeuvre des opérations visant à renforcer
l'inclusion numérique des Français
établis hors de France alors bien sûr il
peut toujours amplifier ces dispositifs
et ses interventions à ce sujet et nous
l'invitons d'ailleurs à le faire mais
pour les deux raisons que j'ai données
nous sommes défavorable à cet amendement
c'est avec du gouvernement
ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Center le Gouvernement est également
défavorable
cette proposition je rappelle que nous
sommes évidemment attachés à rendre
accessible à tous les publics nos
services consultants mais c'est ce que
nous faisons d'abord avec la mise en
place de France consulaire qui est un
service de réponse téléphonique et qui
se déploie progressivement dans un
nombre croissant de pays ensuite un
service d'accueil téléphonique et même
des bornes informatiques sont en place
dans de nombreux consulats et nous
renforçons ce service et enfin dans la
plupart des consulats il est possible de
prendre des rendez-vous lorsque tel ou
telle personne nécessite un accueil
particulier et un accompagnement
personnalisé merci le 1278 deux avis
négatifs qui est pour
merci monsieur le Président 15 États
encore dans le monde interdisent
complètement l'accès à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans de
nombreuses autres celui-ci est limité à
certains cas y compris en Europe en cas
de viol inceste malformation du fœtus ou
danger pour la vie de la mer
même lorsque l'avortement est légal
certains professionnels de santé
refusent de
faire des IVG pour des raisons
religieuses morales etc je pense
particularité à l'Italie laissant des
milliers de femmes dans un état de
détresse comme toujours 72% des
personnes ayant avorté était sous
contraception et une femme et personne
menstrues sur trois à avorter ou
avortera dans sa vie que ce soit en
France ou à l'étranger les Françaises
qui vivent à l'étranger doivent pouvoir
être amenés en France en cas d'urgence
afin de pouvoir bénéficier de leur droit
fondamental à disposer de leur corps
imaginez qu'on laisse une française au
Brésil sans aide aucune à 12 semaines de
grossesse avec une impossibilité de
payer un billet d'avion exorbitant pour
respecter le délai de 14 semaines cela
n'est pas acceptable c'est pourquoi je
vous propose d'inclure un budget de
500.000 euros pour assurer le
rapatriement sanitaire exceptionnel pour
réaliser une interruption volontaire de
grossesse en France à toute personne
française résidant à l'étranger qui le
demande
avis de la commission
merci monsieur le Président donc
l'amendement que vient de présenter
madame Vogel vise à créer un programme
pour financer des opérations de
rapatriement au bénéfice de femmes de
nationalité française qui veulent
réaliser une IVG qui ne peut être
réalisé dans leur pays de résidence je
pense que la question doit être prise
très au sérieux y compris dans des bas
que nous avons aujourd'hui sur l'accès à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et notre interrogation elle est est-ce
qu'il faut créer un programme spécifique
qui correspondent à une politique
publique spécifique au sens où là lol
fait l'exige sachant qu'un tel programme
pourrait révéler aussi au pays de
résidence le motif du rapatriement de la
femme en France ou alors les moyens dont
dispose les postes diplomatiques pour
accompagner les personnes nécessitant un
rapatriement d'urgence suffit-il ou
devrait-il être abondé sans que soit
créé un programme spécifique indiquant
le motif du rapatriement donc nous avons
demandé un avis du gouvernement sur
cette question du gouvernement
monsieur Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs je voudrais d'abord
rappeler que la règle en matière de
rapatriement et de rechercher le
financement par l'intéressé ou par ses
proches ou bien de rechercher l'avance
remboursable des frais pour mémoire sur
la page 32 du passeport français figure
ceci les postes diplomatiques et
consulaires français ne prennent pas en
charge les frais de séjour et de
rapatriement il serait même si je
comprends ce qui motive cette amendement
il serait particulièrement inéquitable
de réserver de nouvelles dispositions
aux personnes qui recherchent
rapatriement pour interruption
volontaire de grossesse et de ne pas
faire de même pour des compatriotes
atteints de pathologies graves qui
pourraient également avoir besoin de se
faire soigner en France et donc le
dispositif qui vaut à l'heure actuelle
nous paraît suffisant raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement défavorable cet
amendement la mise en place n'aura pas
trop sanitaire d'urgence est possible
est possible quoique exceptionnel et se
fait après instruction du dossier sur
une base individuelle au regard de la
situation médicale du patient
défavorable sagesse alors 1271 un avis
de sagesse de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
merci qui est contre
on recommence et levez vraiment la main
qui est pour
merci quiconque
il est adopté le 1216 monsieur Leleu
oui monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues l'Assemblée des Français de
l'étranger ne disposent pas du budget
suffisant tout simplement pour
fonctionner correctement cette
amendement a donc trois objectifs
principaux
tout d'abord il vise donc principalement
renforcer le budget de l'Assemblée des
Français de l'Étranger à améliorer les
conditions de travail des conseillers à
l'Assemblée des Français de l'étranger
en renforçant le secrétariat de cette
assemblée il conviendrait que chaque
commission de la fe dispose d'un
secrétariat en charge des rapports et
des études sur les sujets qui les
concernent
il s'agit également de dégager un budget
plus important pour la formation des
conseillers à l'Assemblée des Français
d'étrangers mais aussi des conseillers
des Français de l'étranger
il s'agit enfin d'offrir une cellule
d'expertise et d'assistance dédiée pour
l'ensemble des conseillers des Français
de l'étranger cela permettra aux élus
représentants les Français établir de
France d'effectuer leur mission de
représentation dans de bien meilleures
conditions conditions pardon qu'à
l'heure actuelle je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
avis défavorable de la commission parce
que cette augmentation de crédit
correspond en réalité à une
multiplication par 2,5 par 2,5 des
crédits demandés pour le fonctionnement
de l'Assemblée des Français de
l'étranger ce qui nous paraît un
changement d'échelle et d'organisation
qui ne relève pas comme cela de la loi
de finances mais d'un débat vraiment sur
les buts et les moyens de l'Assemblée
des Français de l'étranger il y avait du
gouvernement
avis défavorable monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
voudrais rappeler également que la
formation des élus est assurée au moyen
d'initiative la direction des Français à
l'étranger et des services de formation
du ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères et qu'il n'y a pas à ce jour
de difficulté de financement connu
merci je mets je vois le 1216 avec deux
avis négatifs qui pour
qui contre
1270 madame Vogel
monsieur le Président donc dans 69 pays
sur 193 l'homosexualité est interdite si
vous êtes gay lesbienne bisexuelle
transgenre intersexes qui aussi le cas
d'un certain nombre de nos compatriotes
à l'étranger vous risquez des amendes la
prison des thérapies forcées de la
violence voir dans de nombreux pays la
peine de mort lorsque vous ne risquez
pas de perdre votre vie ou lorsque vous
ne risquez pas votre sécurité vous
subissez de nombreuses discriminations
interdiction de se marier non
reconnaissance de votre mariage non
reconnaissances du bien parental avec
vos enfants etc en Russie en Pologne en
Hongrie dans certains états des
États-Unis ailleurs il est parfois
simplement interdit d'évoquer votre
existence
ceci conduit de nombreux et de
nombreuses français vivant hors de
France a caché le fait qu'elles sont de
la communauté lgbtqia+ afin de ne pas
vivre sa discrimination et ses violences
la France se doit de protéger tous ses
citoyens et toutes ses citoyens et de
prendre en compte leurs besoins
spécifiques aujourd'hui les Françaises
et les Français LGBT qui a plus
s'expatrian doivent regarder par
eux-mêmes dans chaque pays pour savoir
si ils pourront être accueillis
dignement est-ce que leur identité est
considérée comme un fait illégal dans ce
pays mais également des questions très
concrètes du quotidien comme la possible
inscription de leur partenaire sur un
contrat de location l'enregistrement de
leur conjoint au consulat si il est
possible de s'annoncer comme ils sont
lors des investigations par les bureaux
de l'immigration ou s'il risque quelque
chose ces informations ne sont
aujourd'hui pas disponibles dans les
consulats et elle devrait c'est pourquoi
cette elle le devrait c'est pourquoi cet
abandon propose d'investir pour assurer
la mise à disposition simplement d'un
kit d'information
utile des Françaises et des Français de
l'étranger qui en ont besoin je vous
remercie et commission
oui monsieur le Président chers
collègues cet amendement donc propose de
créer un programme et il nous semble que
les actions proposées présentent un
caractère très ponctuel et circonscrit
et que dès lors elle ne peuvent pas être
regardées comme formant une politique
publique définie au sens de l'article 7
de la LOLF c'est un argument qu'on a
déjà utilisé mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
créer un programme il faut il faut y
penser et d'autre part ces actions nous
apparaissent largement finançables par
le mystère à ce jour a plus forte raison
s'il s'agit essentiellement d'élaborer
des guides ou un recensement de la
situation dans les pays donc nous avons
un avis défavorable avis du gouvernement
avis défavorable également monsieur le
Président et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs la politique des droits de
l'homme du ministère réserve une place
importante à la défense des droits des
LGBT plus qui en fait partie évidemment
et vous vous souvenez madame la
signature je viens de nommer un
ambassadeur spécifiquement chargé de
cette question je voudrais par ailleurs
préciser que des fiches conseils aux
voyageurs existent sont disponibles
accessibles à tous sur France diplomatie
qui comporte systématiquement l'ensemble
des informations nécessaires sur le
statut des personnes et les éventuels
difficultés aux restrictions que
pratiquent certains pays
merci je mets je vois le 1270 avec deux
avis négatifs qui pour
qui contre
le mille cinq monsieur Cadic
retirez le 1232 madame Conway
d'exceptionnel à la ufe à nos deux
établissements scolaires français au
Burkina Faso en effet compte tenu de la
situation sécuritaire du pays qui s'est
dégradé depuis le coup d'État militaire
vous avez vu que même l'interdiction de
diffusion de RFI elle lui a été imposée
on a une situation de plus en plus
difficile pour nos ressortissants
français donc il faut peut-être
anticiper une baisse potentielle des
effectifs qui feraient supporter aux
autres familles une augmentation des
frais de scolarité qui est un concevable
et donc c'était de pourrait aider
l'établissement scolaire merci avis de
la commission
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
avis défavorable de la commission parce
que sans nier la situation très
particulière du Burkina Faso il nous
semble que sur un montant de 100000
euros très faible par rapport à
l'ensemble de la subvention et du budget
de l'AEFE c'est par dans le budget de la
f.et que le soutien pourrait se réaliser
sans besoin d'un amendement spécifique
oui du gouvernement
mais ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs la vie du Gouvernement est
défavorable je remercie madame la
sénatrice de sa préoccupation sur la
réparation des établissements scolaires
comme elle l'a fait tout à l'heure à
propos de l'ambassade mais je dois lui
dire que le mystère en lien parce qu'il
concerne les lycées avec l'aufe a déjà
pris des mesures de réparation
nécessaire des dégâts
identifiés et donc il le fera sur le
long les moyens habituels de gestion de
crise merci je mets je vois le 1232 avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
nous allons procéder au vote des crédits
de la mission action extérieure de
l'État figurant à l'état B je vous
rappelle que la commission des finances
est favorable à l'adoption des crédits
de cette mission je mets au vois les
crédits de la mission qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés nous
allons procéder l'examen de l'amendement
portant sur les objectifs indicateurs de
performance de la mission action
extérieure de l'État figurant à l'état g
amendement de Madame Conway muret 1246
merci monsieur le Président pour pallier
la suppression des standards
téléphoniques dans les postes de
consulaires vous avez fait le choix de
l'externalisation avec la création de la
plateforme de réponse aux appels et
courriels France consulaires burlafaste
d'expérimentation l'outil semble avoir
donné satisfaction mais il reste
perfectible car le retour d'expérience
fait état de certaines réponses
inexactes données par les
téléconseillers du prestataire faute de
formation suffisante aujourd'hui le
déploiement de ce service au niveau
européen nécessite de s'assurer de sa
qualité puisqu'il sera demain le seul
moyen pour les usagers d'obtenir des
réponses à leurs questions pour ce faire
c'est amendement propose donc de créer
un nouvel indicateur intitulé
déploiement du service France consulaire
relatant précisément la durée moyenne de
réponse aux appels et au courriel le
taux de transmission des questions au
deuxième pôle d'encadrement ainsi que le
taux de satisfaction au regard de
l'exactitude des renseignements
prodigués merci avis de la commission
merci monsieur le Président donc le
service France consulaire est une
expérimentation récente qui semble
donner satisfaction même si elle a
aujourd'hui du mal à se déployer à
l'ensemble des pays d'Europe ceci dit
la création d'un indicateur nous paraît
tout à fait pertinent et participé à
l'information et du gouvernement et du
Parlement donc nous donnons un avis
favorable à cet amendement de même que
Noémie
Mesdames et Messieurs les soldataires le
gouvernement défavorable à cet homme on
demande je voudrais rappeler pour
expliquer cette avis défavorable que le
service France consulaire couvre
aujourd'hui 16 pays il se déplorera
d'ici la fin de l'année dans 6 nouveaux
pays après en effet intégration et
formation de nouveaux effectifs mais je
voudrais également et surtout rappeler
que ça n'est pas le seul moyen de
répondre aux questions des usagers bien
au contraire France consulaire permettra
de dégager du temps pour les agents des
consulats qui permettront ainsi d'être
plus accessible souhaitons-le pour nos
compatriotes merci Monsieur Lemoine
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
puisque nous sommes sur l'article 30
liés à la performance je veux dire que
sur cet amendement je pense
qu'effectivement on peut d'autant plus y
aller et bien que les résultats sont
bons et que c'est un indicateur
intéressant mais j'en profite puisqu'on
parle justement obligatif et indicateur
de performance pour dire que à
l'occasion des nombreux débats qui sont
noués sur les amendements précédents sur
sur la mission que nous avons examinée
et bien qu'il me semble qu'il est
important de progresser dans les
prochaines semaines les prochains mois à
travers des groupes de travail ou les
formats Haddock que choisira Madame le
Ministre pour tenir un certain nombre
d'engagements présidentiel qui figure
noir sur blanc dans un sur un formulaire
que le Président de la République
adressé aux Français de l'étranger le
Pass Culture effectivement c'est un
engagement le passe résidence langue
française qui s'apparente beaucoup à
l'amendement que notre collègue caddique
a retiré à l'instant pour ne pas
allonger les débats mais également la
résidence de repli ou d'attache selon le
terme que les les autres prendront donc
il me semble important effectivement que
nous progressions sur ces sujets d'ici
les justement la discussion qui se
réitéra l'année prochaine sur la loi de
finances et dire qu'il est important
également et bien en terme
d'organisation et bien nous puissions là
aussi peut-être faire évoluer parachever
certaines organisations pour avoir cette
vision très interministérielle c'est
d'ailleurs dans le décret des missions
de la DFE que de veiller à la protection
des droits et intérêts des Français de
concourir à la définition d'un certain
nombre de politiques fiscales sociales
et donc important pour faire progresser
des dossiers que j'évoquais et puis
naturellement faire confiance pleinement
aux élus des Français de l'étranger
parce qu'ils ne sont pas des contraintes
environnementales ils sont des atouts
pour avancer je pense au dossier staff
et notamment au moyen dédiés à la fe
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président et
pour cette raison je voterai
l'amendement
de l'amendement merci monsieur de moine
alors vous restez dans les amendements
ça va comme ça monsieur sido vous restez
dans l'amendement oui en plus je serai
très court monsieur le Président je vous
le promets pour avoir été rapporteur de
cette question là nous avons interrogé
les services du ministère des Affaires
étrangères et effectivement en France
consulaire c'est un grand succès mais un
succès qui se développera dans le monde
entier et ça nous a été dit tel que à
l'aune des budgets qui seront alloués à
ce dispositif
donc
1246 avec deux avis défavorables on est
bien d'accord oui ils s'en servent plus
rien bon allez favorable vous êtes
favorable et le Gouvernement est
défavorable on est bien d'accord alors
le 1246 avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
il est adapté
avant l'article 41 a le 1245 madame
Conway Mouret
oui c'est une demande de rapport je sais
pas très populaire mais puisque la
rénovation est énergétique de notre part
immobilier à l'étranger reste l'angle
mort du plan de relance de 4 milliards
d'euros à louer au bâtiment de l'État en
fait ce rapport serait l'occasion pour
le ministère de rassembler toutes les
données de mener une véritable véritable
travail de prospective sur les besoins
qui se relèvera révélera très utile
quand la rénovation énergétique du parc
immobilier de l'État à l'étranger elle
viendra
et avec la commission
chers collègues votre amendement sera
satisfait par le travail que nous
réalisons la mission de contrôle que
nous avons sur les
l'immobilier de l'État et nous
regarderons particulièrement ses besoins
là mais nous avons un avis défavorable
comme la jurisprudence du Sénat en
général sur ces rapports
et de retirer voilà alors dites-moi
qu'il est retiré allez hop le 1247
madame Conway Mouret
qui permettait de venir en aide à
désosser à des associations à hauteur de
3 millions d'euros a été remplacé en
catimini par le dispositif de soutien au
tissu associatif des Français de
l'étranger qui s'appelle le staff ce
système va vite démontré ses limites
puisque ces crédits réduit à 2 millions
d'euros n'ont jamais été pleinement
utilisé parce que les critères étaient
trop restrictifs et parce que la
Commission nationale outre passe
largement s'est prérogatives en
retoquant la moitié des dossiers qui
émanent du terrain de fait nous
observons une démotivation à faire tout
ce travail en amont de sélection sans le
voir aboutir à une diminution
significative du monde du nombre de
demandes de subvention qui est passée de
368 en 2019 à 242 en 2022 dans un groupe
de travail sur les critères
d'éligibilité du staff a été créé avec
les conseillers des Français de
l'étranger s'est réuni une première fois
au début du mois de septembre 2022 alors
c'est amendement propose en fait de
compléter ce travail en demandant au
gouvernement de présenter au Parlement
un rapport à notre élaborer sur la base
des remontées de l'ensemble des
conseillers des Français de l'étranger
et des associations les représentants
permettraient de clarifier les critères
d'éligibilité des subventions et enfin
mettre en place un système dans lequel
le pouvoir décisionnel revient à ceux
qui connaissent le mieux les
associations c'est à dire les conseils
consulaires
ah oui
merci comme il s'agit d'un demande de
rapport la vie de la Commission et
défavorable néanmoins le dispositif
staff à quelques années d'existence
suite à la suppression de la réserve
parlementaire et nous pensons que un
contrôle parlementaire serait tout à
fait judicieux sur la mise en oeuvre du
dispositif staff plutôt qu'un rapport
demandé au gouvernement donc c'est un
avis défavorable sur la forme du rapport
mais sur l'objectif d'une évaluation
nous pensons aussi nécessairement
la vie défavorable monsieur le Président
le groupe de travail sur les critères
d'éligibilité du dispositif staff vient
de commencer ses travaux il va aller
poursuivre afin d'explorer les
possibilités d'évolution des critères du
dispositif mais en vue d'une prise en
compte pour la campagne 2024 donc ça
nous paraît prématuré raison pour
laquelle le Gouvernement émet un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
il est maintenu monsieur Chantrel
oui par rapport madame la ministre au
groupe de travail moi je peux vous
soumettre des idées parce que j'ai siégé
moi-même dans cette commission nationale
d'attribution du staff c'est sûr ça a
mis fin à la réserve parlementaire vous
pouvez éventuellement avoir des conflits
d'intérêts une certaine dérive
clientéliste avec ce trader moi j'étais
favorable à sa suppression mais il y
avait une certaine souplesse dans
l'attribution dans son attribution qu'on
a perdu avec l'usine à gaz qui est le
staff justement
usine à gaz puisque normalement au
niveau local moi je serais tenté de vous
dire au niveau du groupe de travail
faites confiance au terrain au niveau
local vous avez des conseils consulaires
ou siège l'administration qui valide des
dossiers localement qui sont retoqués
ensuite au niveau national si vous
prenez le dernier exercice qui a eu lieu
justement en 2022 sans passer par la
commission nationale au niveau
budgétaire sa rentrée parfaitement dans
les crédits de 2 millions 1 alors que le
budget comme ça a été très bien évoqué
par par ma collègue a été diminué donc
en fait il suffit juste de faire
confiance au local où les gens savent
qu'est-ce qu'il y a où on a besoin
d'intervenir pour aider nos associations
françaises et pas mettre des des choses
supplémentaires des strates
supplémentaires qui font qu'à l'arrivée
on avait supprimé presque la moitié des
propositions émanant des conseils
consulaires donc en fait la réforme au
niveau du groupe de travail elle est
très simple c'est la simplification des
critères très larges qui permettent de
laisser les élus sur le terrain avec
l'administration qui décide au sein du
Conseil du consulat également pour
choisir ses dossiers et puis vous
retoquez si jamais on dépasse
l'enveloppe budgétaire ça n'était pas le
cas la dernière fois donc c'est tout
c'est c'est les réformes que nous vous
proposons c'est je mets aux voix
l'amendement 1247 avec deux avis
négatifs qui pour
il y a 4 amendements identiques dont un
de la Commission de
monsieur le Président cet amendement
vise à supprimer l'article 41A
cet article a été introduit par le
gouvernement lorsqu'il a engagé sa
responsabilité avec le 49.3 à
l'Assemblée nationale cet article vise à
instituer un comité de gestion chargé de
gérer de diriger les établissements
scolaires actuellement placé en gestion
directe par l'Agence pour l'enseignement
français à l'étranger
c'est un article qui a créé une certaine
émotion ces dernières semaines et nous
proposons de le supprimer pour deux
raisons d'une part sur une pour une
raison de fond nous estimons que le
dispositif proposé aurait des effets
extrêmement importants sur la gestion de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger sur
l'équilibre entre les établissements en
gestion directe et l'agence elle-même et
pour ceux même pour ceux qui penseraient
que cette évolution serait opportune je
ne pense pas que ce soit par le biais
d'une un article d'une loi de finances
non discutée en plus au Parlement que
cela puisse se faire sans même avoir
concerté avec l'ensemble des acteurs
auparavant ensuite dans un sur une
question plus juridique et nous semble
que ce dispositif se borne à réviser à
réviser les modalités de la gouvernance
de la EFE et de ses relations
financières notamment avec les
établissements que c'est sans incidence
sur les dépenses sur les dépenses
budgétaires de l'État et que cela
pourrait donc être censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel comme n'ayant
aucun lien avec le domaine des lois de
finances lui-même voilà pourquoi par cet
amendement nous proposons de supprimer
l'article 41A
merci alors les trois autres sont
identiques vous n'êtes pas forcé de me
refaire le même la même démonstration le
211 monsieur Leleu
quoi oui défendu le 358 monsieur Kern
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre nous sommes sur la même
longueur d'onde que les deux commissions
précédentes donc la commission culture
dit qu'il est défendu merci et le 1254
madame Conway Mouret
un point parce que le rapporteur à 10 je
pense que le coeur de notre réseau
aujourd'hui constitué par les uj les
conventionnés qu'on n'a pas besoin de le
changer pour agrandir le réseau
atteindre le doublement des apprenants
puisque cela se fait au gré de la
création de l'établissement partenaires
qui naissent je pense qu'il a des
besoins sur le terrain et tout cela est
très bien
avis du gouvernement madame la ministre
monsieur Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs je me remettrai votre
sagesse même si en effet la forme
juridique du comité de gestion qui avait
été instauré et fragile juridiquement
ces établissements en gestion directe ne
dispose pas de la personnalité morale
donc elle n'est pas distincte de celle
de l'AEFE et donc il n'est pas possible
de prévoir que certains services de
l'AFE soient gérés par une structure qui
serait extérieure à l'agence
c'est parfait
sinon je lève à 18h non monsieur qui a
dit que je vous ai pas donné la parole
si personne ne respecte les règles moi
je peux lever dire que je suis à 3h30 on
en finit alors allez-y
non mais là franchement merci monsieur
le Président de me donner la parole
puisque je souhaite avoir une
explication de vote puisque je souhaite
voter contre l'amendement je pense que
c'est encore possible et donc donc voilà
tout simplement pour dire que le compte
les comptes des EGD sont consolidés
lorsqu'ils sont présentés au Conseil
administration l'article 41A permettait
de faire la transparence sur les flux
financiers au sein des OGD et nous
parlons de centaines de millions d'euros
cela permettrait le contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement c'est pour ça que nous
sommes normalement ici voilà c'est pour
ça donc je voterai contre ces
amendements merci
d'autres explications de votre compte
je n'en vois pas sur ces quatre
amendements identiques avec un vide
sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour
je dis bien qui est pour les quatre
amendements identiques avec sagesse du
gouvernement
qui est contre
ils sont adoptés
l'article 41 et naturellement supprimer
et il nous reste un amendement le 1244
de Madame Conway Mouret
j'ai pas utilisé plus de 30 secondes
donc je vais faire très vite l'un des
principaux obstacles le développement de
notre réseau éducatif à l'étranger
réside dans l'incapacité à la weve à
emprunter pour financer ses
investissements immobiliers laquelle
s'est ajoutée la double peine de la
suppression de la garantie de l'État en
2017 très concrètement pour accueillir
davantage d'élèves comme le souhaite le
président de la République les
établissements auront besoin d'ouvrir
des classes et donc d'agrandir les
bâtiments or elle est contraintes
aujourd'hui par la loi de programmation
des finances publiques qui interdit aux
organismes divers d'administration
centrale de recourir aux emprunts de
plus de 12 mois et par le contrat
d'objectifs de moyens de 2021-2023 qui
prévoit la fin de la possibilité pour
l'opérateur de recourir aux avances de
l'Agence France Trésor à partir de 2023
donc on a un certain nombre de pistes
qui pourraient permettre de financer des
opérations militaires immobilières
pardon et c'est amendement demande au
gouvernement de présenter un rapport
étudiant ces trois possibilités afin de
permettre l'expansion du réseau
d'enseignement français à l'étranger
avis de la commission
avait du gouvernement
je mets aux voiles 1244 avec deux avis
des favorables qui pour
qui contre
il est rejeté
nous en avons terminé avec l'action
extérieure et nous passons à l'examen de
la mission être public au développement
et du compte spécial prêt à des États
étrangers quelques secondes le temps du
changement en tout cas en commission